Hey everyone, we are just popping on to say a quick hello and share some news. We have a new podcasting partner! That's right! Starting August 14th, we will be partnering with the Odyssey Broadcasting Company to finish our rewatch and start the next chapter of Office Ladies. Yes, it is so exciting! And you know, I was just home visiting my family in Texas and I shared this news with them and my sister asked if this changes anything for our listeners.
大家好，我们冒泡出来简单打个招呼，顺便分享一个好消息。我们有了一个新的播客合作伙伴！没错！从8月14日开始，我们将与奥德赛广播公司合作，完成我们的重看之旅，并开启《办公室女士》的下一篇章。是的，太令人兴奋了！而且你知道，我之前刚回家去德州看望家人，我把这个消息告诉了他们，我妹妹就问这会不会给我们听众带来任何改变。
And I thought that was a really good question. The answer is it does not. That's right. You will still get your podcast every Wednesday wherever you listen to Office Ladies. And you know, we are already loving everyone at Odyssey, but we also want to thank the folks at Earwulf who we hold near and dear to our hearts for believing in office ladies from day one and everyone we worked with at SiriusXM. We will miss you all and we are so thankful for the friendships we made along the way.
我觉得这是一个非常好的问题。答案是不会。没错。无论你在哪里收听《办公室女士》，你依然可以在每周三听到我们的播客。而且你知道的，我们已经很喜欢奥德赛的每一位成员了，但我们也要感谢Earwulf的朋友们，我们对他们怀有深深的感激之情，感谢他们从第一天起就对《办公室女士》坚信不疑，还要感谢我们在SiriusXM合作过的所有人。我们会想念大家的，也非常感谢一路走来收获的友谊。
Yeah. Now, we are going to need a little transition time, so we're going to take an extended summer break. For the next four weeks, we're gonna be rerunning episodes. Cassie had the really fun idea of rerunning our first four episodes from season five. Yes! I loved this. I did too, and we also went back into our mailbag because we thought it might be fun to kick off each rerun with a couple of extra tidbits. I love tidbits. We do. I'll start us off. All right, so today we are rerunning Weight Loss Part 1 and to kick off each rerun with a couple extra tidbits. I love tidbits. We do.
是的。现在，我们需要一段过渡时间，所以我们要延长暑假。在接下来的四周里，我们将重播一些剧集。卡茜（Cassie）有个非常有趣的提议，就是重播我们第五季的前四集。没错！我很喜欢这个主意。我也是，而且我们还翻找了我们的听众信箱，因为我们觉得在每集重播开始时，加几个额外的趣闻可能会很有趣。我喜欢趣闻。我们都很喜欢。我来开个头。好吧，所以今天我们要重播《减肥》（上集），并在每集重播开始时加几个额外的趣闻。我喜欢趣闻。我们都很喜欢。
I'll start us off. All right, so today we are rerunning Weight Loss Part 1. Angela, what have you got for us? Well, if you remember, one of the storylines in this episode is about Andy and Angela's wedding. Andy is really trying to plan the perfect wedding for Angela, and she just hates every suggestion that he has. Well, because she doesn't really want to marry him.
我来开个头。好吧，今天我们要重播《减肥》（上集）。安吉拉，你给我们准备了什么？嗯，如果你还记得的话，这一集的主线剧情之一是关于安迪和安吉拉的婚礼。安迪真的很努力地为安吉拉筹划完美的婚礼，而她却讨厌他提出的每一个建议。嗯，因为她其实并不想嫁给他。
Well, I know. Right. And a few folks wrote in to ask if there were any good alts in the candy bag for an Andy talking head. Okay, it's the one where Andy says, every little boy fantasizes about his fairy tale wedding. Yes, I remember this. I looked.
嗯，我知道。没错。有几位听众来信问，在糖果袋里有没有关于安迪单独采访的好替代片段。好吧，就是安迪说的那段话：每个小男孩都幻想过自己的童话婚礼。是的，我记得这个。我查过了。
There were a bunch. I can't believe I didn't even share them on our first watch of this. Here are two alts that really cracked me up. Andy says, am I looking forward to my wedding? Obvs. Am I looking forward to marrying Angela? Deafs. Is she looking forward to marrying me?
有很多呢。真不敢相信我在第一次看的时候居然没分享过。这里有两个让我笑喷的替代片段。安迪说：“我期待我的婚礼吗？那是当然。我期待娶安吉拉吗？绝对的。她期待嫁给我吗？
Probs. Not totes, paws though. I love it. Very Andy. Very Andy. Here's another one. Not totes paws though. I love it. Very Andy. Very Andy. Here's another one. I can't stop thinking about our wedding day.
可能吧。倒也不是百分百，不过爪子形状嘛（意指开玩笑）。我很喜欢。太安迪了。太安迪了。这里还有另一个。倒也不是百分百，不过爪子形状嘛。我很喜欢。太安迪了。太安迪了。这里还有另一个。我脑子里一直想着我们的婚礼那天。
I gasp when I see Angela coming down the aisle. She's a vision in white. There's a dove in her hair. I nail the singing of our first dance song. I do some quick robot moves. She's impressed. The mayor's applauding. I do some quick robot moves. She's impressed. The mayor's applauding. I wink at a flower girl. She remembers it forever. And then I take home my blushing bride and have sex for the first time in eight years." Wow. Yeah. That talking head
当我看到安吉拉走过红毯时，我倒吸了一口气。她穿着白纱宛如仙女。她的头发上有一只鸽子。我完美地唱出了我们的第一支舞曲。我做了一些快速的机器人动作。她印象深刻。市长在鼓掌。我做了一些快速的机器人动作。她印象深刻. 市长在鼓掌。我对花童眨了眨眼。她一辈子都会记住的。然后我把满脸羞涩的新娘带回家，进行了我八年来的第一次性生活。”哇。是啊，那个单人采访
reminds me a little bit of Dwight's talking head, where he talks about being the spy. Remember that one that goes like 50 directions? Yes, it has a lot of twists and turns. All right, well lady, I have a little tidbit. I saw this letter in our digital mailbag and it made me chuckle. So you know, in this episode, Pam goes away to art school in New York
让我想起了一点德怀特的单人采访，就是他谈到自己是个间谍的那段。还记得那段像有50个走向的采访吗？是的，有很多曲折离奇的转折。好吧，女士，我有一个小趣闻。我在我们的数字信箱里看到了这封信，它逗得我咯咯直笑。所以你知道的，在这集里，帕姆去了纽约的艺术学校
and you see Jim and Pam communicating on instant message. Oh yeah. Old tech alert. And you can see their screen names. Anna Jo wrote in to say, who came up with the screen names Jim9334 and receptionitis15? I will tell you, the answer is John Krasinski.
然后你看到吉姆和帕姆通过即时通讯软件交流。哦，对了。老旧科技警报。而且你可以看到他们的网名。安娜·乔（Anna Jo）来信说，是谁想出了Jim9334和receptionitis15这两个网名的？我来告诉你，答案是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。
Really? Because John went around to our computers and set up instant message. When we got the internet, he did this so that we could joke around in the background of scenes. He did it. They didn't do this in the crew. I got to work one day and he was like, check it out. He showed me my little instant message screen and that my name was receptionitis15.
真的吗？因为约翰转了好几台我们的电脑，设置了即时通讯。当我们有了网络之后，他这么做是为了让我们能在场景的背景里开玩笑。他做的。剧组人员可没这么干。有一天我去上班，他说，你瞧。他把我的小即时通讯界面展示给我看，上面显示我的名字叫receptionitis15。
I was like, what is this name? He's like, I don't know. Well, I remember that he talked us through the rest of us how to do it. Yes. Do you remember what your I am screen name was by any chance? I do. We were so tickled that we could now I am each other during scenes. Mine was Ms. Accountant. Ms. Accountant. Yeah. Oh my gosh. We really kept on theme for our characters. Well listen, we weren't just IMing each other either. I would IM with fans during scenes.
我当时就想，这算什么名字？他说，我不知道。嗯，我记得他跟我们其他人讲解了怎么操作。没错。你还碰巧记得你当时的即时通讯网名是什么吗？我记得。我们当时觉得太好玩了，竟然可以在拍摄场景时给对方发即时消息。我的是Ms. Accountant（会计女士）。Ms. Accountant。是啊。噢天哪。我们真的很符合我们角色的主题。听着，我们可不仅仅是互相发即时消息。我甚至会在拍摄场景时给粉丝发消息。
Remember when we had MySpace? Somehow I think I would get the IM of fans through MySpace and I would write things and I would say, when you watch the episode healthcare, there's gonna be a scene where Dwight is talking about hot dog fingers and I'm IMing you during this scene. Wow, I don't think I had figured that out. Yeah, that was something I think BJ Novak might have.
还记得我们有MySpace的时候吗？不知怎么的，我想我会通过MySpace收到粉丝的即时消息，我会写一些东西，然后我说，当你看到《健康保险》那一集时，会有一个场景是德怀特在谈论热狗手指，我会在这个场景拍摄时给你发即时消息。哇，我觉得我当时还没弄明白这事。对，那好像是BJ·诺瓦克可能……
Yeah, I kind of remember now you guys doing that and we'd be like, what? You're talking to people right now? Yeah, yeah, I didn't do it, but I remember you guys. Well, everyone, there are your new weight loss part one tidbits. And thank you for hanging in there while we take this little break to transition to our new podcasting partner Odyssey. We will be back breaking down the rest of season nine on August 14th with The Farm. But in the meantime, here's Weight Loss, part one. I'm Jenna Fisher.
对，我隐约记起你们当时这么干过，我们就会觉得，什么？你现在在跟别人说话？对，对，我没这么干，不过我记得你们有。好了各位，这就是你们关于《减肥》（上集）的新趣闻。感谢大家在我们进行短暂休息、过渡到新播客合作伙伴奥德赛期间对我们的支持。我们将于8月14日带着《农场》回归，继续剖析第九季的剩余内容。不过在此之前，请收听《减肥》（上集）。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重看播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历过的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hi everyone. Hey! Oh my gosh. Why are we screaming already? We'll tell you. We are back in the studio. We are in the studio. We are vaccinated.
大家好。嘿！噢天哪。我们为什么已经在尖叫了？我们来告诉你。我们回到了录音室。我们在录音室里。我们接种了疫苗。
Our team is vaccinated. Look at this. I can put my arms around you. I can put my arms around you. I can put my arms around you. I can put my arms around you. I can put my arms tell you. We are back in the studio. We are in the studio. We are vaccinated. Our team is vaccinated. Look at this. I can put my arms all the way out to the sides and I don't touch any clothes or any walls. I am not staring at you through my husband's t-shirts or smelling his socks. It's so exciting. Lady, I'm looking at your face in real life.
我们的团队都接种了疫苗。看这个。我可以把双臂搭在你身上。我可以把双臂搭在你身上。我可以把双臂搭在你身上。我可以把双臂搭在你身上。我可以把双臂告诉你。我们回到了录音室。我们在录音室里。我们接种了疫苗。我们的团队都接种了疫苗。看这个。我可以把双臂完全向两边展开，而不会碰到任何衣服或墙壁。我不用透过我丈夫T恤的孔洞盯着你看，也不用闻他的袜子。太激动了。女士，我正在现实生活中看着你的脸。
It's weird. I want to touch it, but I won't. Can I get you on a Zoom? Actually, will you go in the other room? Can we do this over Zoom? We are thrilled to be here. It's been over a year. Over a year?
这感觉好奇怪。我想摸摸它，但我不会。我能跟你视频通话吗？其实，你能去别的房间吗？我们能通过视频做这个吗？我们很高兴能来到这里。已经一年多了。一年多了？
Yeah. We don't know what this is going to be, guys. We ended up doing more Office Ladies podcasts from our closet than we ever did in person. Crazy. But we're back in person now and we don't know what's going to happen. I'll tell you a few changes right off the bat. Angela has stopped using note cards, guys, and I'm freaking out. And post-its. Sam is clapping from the engineer booth. It's a moment of growth, you guys. I have a Word document now. I put everything in. It's very adulty.
是啊。大家，我们不知道这会变成什么样。我们最终在衣帽间里录制的《办公室女士》播客比以往任何面对面录制的都要多。太疯狂了。但我们现在又面对面录制了，而且我们不知道会发生什么。我马上告诉你们几个变化。大家注意，安吉拉已经不用手写卡了，我快要抓狂了。还有便利贴。萨姆在工程控制室里鼓掌。大家伙儿，这是一个成长的时刻。我现在用Word文档了。我把所有东西都记在里面。非常具有成年人的成熟感。
I'm not saying I'm gonna stick with it. Maybe it was something I started doing because I was in my closet and I just didn't have space for all my note cards, but look at me at this big table now. I know, it's almost like you wanna fill it up with note cards, don't you? A little bit, a little bit, a little bit. Well, the other big news for today
我不是说我会一直坚持下去。也许这只是我因为呆在衣帽间里才开始做的事，因为我的衣帽间实在放不下所有的手写卡，但瞧瞧现在坐在大桌子旁的我。我知道，这感觉就像你恨不得用手写卡把桌子填满一样，对吧？有一点，有一点，有一点。好吧，今天的另一个大新闻
is that we are kicking off season five of The Office with Weight Loss Part One. Season flipping five. Yeah. We're here. Here we are. Let's do it.
就是我们将以《减肥》（上集）开启《办公室》第五季。见鬼的第五季。没错。我们到了。我们在这儿。开始吧。
This is season five, episode one, written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky, directed by Paul Feig. We stopped talking. We already don't know what we're doing. Do you know what I was going to do? I was going to go, boo-boo, boo-boo, boo. And then I was like, no, that's annoying. So then I said nothing.
这是第五季第一集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯普尼斯基编剧，保罗·费格执导。我们不说话了。我们已经不知道该做什么了。你知道我刚才想做什么吗？我本想说，布-布，布-布，布。然后我觉得，算了，这太烦人了。所以我什么也没说。
And then you said nothing. And then we just stared at each other. You know why? Because we can. There might be a lot of long pauses in this podcast today. I'm going to move us into a summary. The gang at Dunder Mifflin participates in an eight-week company-wide weight loss competition. Pam begins her three-month design program in New York City,
然后你什么也没说。然后我们就大眼瞪小眼地看着对方。你知道为什么吗？因为我们能这么做。今天的这期播客里可能会有很多长时间的停顿。我要把话题引入剧情总结。邓德米夫林的全体员工参加了一个为期八周的全公司减肥比赛。帕姆在纽约开始她为期三个月的设计项目，
and Andy attempts to get Angela to commit to wedding plans, but she's busy. She's having an affair with Dwight, an affair. I know, she is stressed the F out. And the minute Andy asked her about the wedding, she runs to Dwight. Yeah, I have a question about that. Why can't you guys like have sex at home? Like after work? Are you guys having sex at home after work
安迪则试图让安吉拉承诺筹备婚礼，但她很忙。她正在和德怀特偷情，偷情。我知道，她压力大得要命。安迪一问她关于婚礼的事，她就跑去找德怀特。对，我对此有个疑问。为什么你们不能在家里做爱呢？比如下班后？你们是在下班后回家做爱
or is it only in the warehouse? That is such a good question I've never thought about. I mean, I definitely see their hookups in this episode whenever Angela is spiraling. Yeah. Maybe she's happy at home with all of her cats and maybe she doesn't let Andy come over so she doesn't need Dwight to cope. Yeah. Or maybe they're just shagging everywhere. I don't know. Well, we'll discuss more later. everywhere. I don't know. Well, we'll discuss more later. We'll discuss more. Guys, this was the start of our fifth season, like we said, and to make up for the shorter fourth season that got interrupted because of the writer's strike, NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. So this season has the most episodes of any office season. Oh my God, I didn't know that.
还是只在仓库里？这是一个我从没想过的好问题。我的意思是，我绝对能看出每当安吉拉情绪崩溃时，他们就会在这集里偷情。对。也许她在家里被所有的猫咪包围着很开心，也许她不让安迪过来，所以她不需要靠德怀特来应对。对，或者他们只是到处乱搞。我不知道。好吧，我们稍后再讨论。到处乱搞。我不知道。好吧，我们稍后再讨论。我们会深入讨论的。各位，这是我们第五季的开端，正如我们所说，为了弥补因编剧罢工而中断的较短的第四季，全国广播公司为第五季订购了28集。所以这一季是《办公室》所有季中集数最多的一季。噢天哪，我以前不知道。
Yeah. That's some good office trivia, my lady. Thank you. Thank you. Well, it's going to move us into fast fact number one, which is a little complicated. I'll tell you why. OK.
是啊。女士，这可是一些很棒的办公室冷知识。谢谢你。谢谢。好吧，接下来我们要进入第一条速查趣闻，它有点复杂。原因我来告诉你。好的。
Back at the end of season three, we said that Rashida Jones left the show and stopped playing Karen Filippelli because she had to go do Parks and Recreation. Was she not going to do Parks and Rec then? She wasn't, Anne, because Parks and Recreation did not exist yet. Parks and Recreation does not exist
回想第三季末，我们曾说过拉什达·琼斯离开剧组不再饰演凯伦·菲利佩利，因为她得去拍《公园与游憩》。难道她当时不用去拍《公园与游憩》吗？安妮，她不用，因为《公园与游憩》当时根本不存在。《公园与游憩》直到
until the middle of season five of The Office. Oh, farts. We got that wrong, m'lady. We did. Why am I saying m'lady? I don't know. Is m'lady the new lady? I hope not, because people right now are like,
《办公室》第五季中段才出现。噢，屁啦。我们搞错了，女士。确实。我为什么总叫女士？我不知道。女士是新的口头禅吗？我希望不是，因为现在的人听了大概会觉得
my ears are bleeding. Stop saying m'lady. Wait, so was she leaving to do a different project? No, she left because they finished the storyline of Karen, Jim, and Pam. It was a storyline thing. I mean, she did go on to do more projects. She did a bunch of movies in that time.
耳朵都在流血。别再叫女士了。等等，那她当时离开是为了去拍别的项目吗？没有，她离开是因为凯伦、吉姆和帕姆的故事线结束了。这是剧情安排。我的确，她后来确实去拍了更多项目。那段时间她拍了一堆电影。
But no, it was a storyline thing. Similarly, I'll have you know that we wondered during branch wars if the photo of Hillary Clinton in her office was a nod to Leslie Knope loving Hillary Clinton. We thought that it was. It wasn't because again, there was no Leslie Knope. There was no Parks and Rec yet.
但不是的，这是剧情安排。同样地，我得告诉你们，我们在拍《分部大战》时曾好奇，她办公室里挂着希拉里·克劳9的照片是不是在向热爱希拉里·克劳9的莱斯利·克诺普致敬。我们当时以为是的。其实并不是，因为还是那句话，当时根本没有莱斯利·克诺普。《公园与游憩》还没诞生呢。
We were determined to pull up Parks and Rec by a few years. Well, I love Parks and Rec, so. I know. Okay, well, there you go. We got that wrong. So this is important for two reasons. One, we need to know the timeline of Parks and Rec. Clearly.
我们硬生生地把《公园与游憩》的时间线提前了好几年。好吧，我很喜欢《公园与游憩》，所以……我也喜欢。好吧，总之就是这样。我们搞错了。所以这件事很重要，原因有二。第一，我们需要弄清楚《公园与游憩》的时间线。显然是的。
And number two, Greg Daniels, who created the American version of The Office, he created Parks and Rec, along with one of our writers, Mike Schor. So midway through this season five, we're gonna lose both Greg and Mike because they're gonna be working on Parks and Rec. And that is why Jen Salata and Paul Eberstein take over as the show runners
第二，创作了美版《办公室》的格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他和我们的编剧之一迈克·舒尔一同创作了《公园与游憩》。所以在第五季的中途，我们要失去格雷格和迈克了，因为他们要去制作《公园与游憩》。这就是为什么詹·萨拉塔和保罗·埃伯斯坦接任了
for season five. All right. There you go. Now, Mike sure moved to Parks and Rec full time. Greg was doing both shows. Greg did a little bit of Parks and Rec. He did a little Office. He bounced back and forth.
第五季的剧集运作人。好吧。就是这样。现在，迈克·舒尔全职转到了《公园与游憩》。格雷格两边兼顾。格雷格做了一点《公园与游憩》。又做了一点《办公室》。他两头跑。
He did, yes. Just wanted us to get that timeline correct. Yes. All right, fast fact number two. Writer of this episode, Gene Stupnitsky, said that the idea for a weight loss episode had been on the writer's wall for a really long time, but they couldn't figure out how to do it in one day.
他确实这么做了，是的。只是想让我们把这个时间线弄对。好的。接下来是第二条速查趣闻。本集的编剧吉恩·斯普尼斯基说，制作减肥主题剧集的想法在编剧室的白板上已经挂了很久很久了，但他们一直想不出该如何在一天之内拍完。
Because remember, they had that rule where they tried to have plot lines that only cover one workday. Right. When NBC asked for the premiere of season five to be an hour long, Greg Daniels had the idea that we could do the weight loss episode as a sort of summer retrospective.
因为你们还记得吧，他们有一条不成文的规定，就是尽量让剧情只覆盖一个工作日。没错。当全国广播公司要求第五季的首播集时长为一小时的时候，格雷格·丹尼尔斯萌生了一个想法，我们可以把减肥这一集拍成一种夏日回顾的形式。
Right, because we never see the characters over the summer. Yeah, Gene said this was a really cool opportunity to see the characters over their summertime, and that they almost called this episode summer. Huh. You might notice also for this episode, there is no cold open. It just starts with the opening credits. Gene said that there was a cold open in the script.
对，因为我们在剧中从未见过角色们过夏天的样子。对，吉恩说这是一个非常棒的机会，能让我们看到角色们度过夏天，他们甚至差点把这一集命名为《夏天》。哼。大家可能也会注意到，这一集没有冷开场。它直接从片头字幕开始。吉恩说剧本里其实是有冷开场的。
It was written that way, but they actually just folded it in to the plot. And he said that the pacing of this episode is a little quicker than previous seasons. This is going to become kind of our new pacing moving forward. And that this was a change they made so they could fit in more jokes and more supporting character storylines. I mean, I definitely noticed I felt like it clipped along. Yes. Fast fact number three, this episode has an all crew commentary. Angela, take it away.
剧本是那样写的，但他们实际上把它融入到了剧情中。并且他说这一集的节奏比前几季要快一些。这在未来将成为我们的一种新节奏。而且这是一个改变，为的是能塞进更多笑话和更多配角的故事线。我的意思是，我确实注意到了，我觉得剧情推进得很利落。没错。第三条速查趣闻，这一集有全剧组的评论音轨。安吉拉，你来揭晓吧。
It does. You guys, when I started listening to this DVD commentary and realized it was all crew, I called Jenna right away. It was one of the best DVD commentaries I've listened to up until now. It's so good. And you've listened to all of them. I have. And I want to share with you guys who is on this DVD commentary for weight loss.
确实有。伙计们，当我开始听这个DVD评论音轨，并意识到里面全是剧组成员时，我立刻给珍娜打了电话。这是我迄今为止听过的最好的DVD评论音轨之一。太棒了。而且你把所有的音轨都听过了。我听过。我想跟你们分享一下，都有谁参与了《减肥》这一集的DVD评论。
Okay, it's phenomenal, it's great. So much information. At the beginning of the DVD commentary, everyone in the crew went around, said their names, and their job title for this episode. Okay. Randy Cordray, our brand new line producer. Michael Gallenberg, our production designer,
好的，太绝了，太棒了。信息量巨大。在DVD评论的开头，剧组的每个人轮流报上自己的名字以及他们在这一集中的职位。好。兰迪·科德雷，我们全新的制片主任。迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的美术指导，
Brian Whittle, our boom operator, Nick Carbone, our sound utility, Ben Patrick, our production sound mixer, Alicia Raycraft, our new costume designer, Kelly Cantley, our first assistant director, and Jake Oust, our post producer. Oh my gosh, what was it like to hear all of their voices again?
布赖恩·惠特尔，我们的挑杆录音师，尼克·卡尔博尼，我们的音频助理，本·帕特里克，我们的制作混音师，艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫特，我们的新服装设计师，凯莉·坎特利，我们的第一副导演，还有杰克·奥斯特，我们的后期制作人。噢天哪，再次听到他们的声音是什么感觉？
It was so wonderful. And you know, Kelly Cantley, I loved her so much. And Jenna, we still are on each other's Christmas card list. We send each other Christmas cards every year. And I just adore her. And I texted her. I said, Kelly, I can't tell you how wonderful it is. I just spent an hour with you, like listening to your voice.
太美妙了。而且你知道的，凯莉·坎特利，我太喜欢她了。珍娜，我们至今还在彼此的圣诞贺卡名单上。我们每年都会给对方寄圣诞贺卡。我非常崇拜她。我给她发了短信。我说，凯莉，我无法形容这种感觉有多美妙。我刚刚跟你相处了一个小时，就像在听你说话一样。
I miss you so much. And she was like, Ange, I miss you too much. And she was like, and I miss you too. And I get her Christmas cards too from her and her husband, Kevin, and their two dogs. I look forward to them every year. There is so much awesome information about the making of weight loss one and two. First thing I wanna share with you guys
我太想你了。她说，安吉，我也超级想你。她说，我也想你。我也会收到她、她丈夫凯文以及他们两只狗狗寄来的圣诞贺卡。我每年都很期待。关于《减肥》（上下集）的制作幕后，有太多太棒的信息了。我要和大家分享的第一件事
that this was Randy and Alicia's first episode that they ever worked on on the office. And what an enormous, huge way to start their time on the show. So normally one episode, as Jenna said, is one day. They had to take our show over the course of eight weeks in one episode. It was a continuity nightmare.
就是这是兰迪和艾莉西亚在《办公室》参与制作的第一集。以如此宏大、惊人的方式开启他们在剧组的时光。通常情况下，正如珍娜所说，一集的故事发生在你的一天之内。而他们却不得不在一集里把我们长达八周的剧情展现出来。这简直是一场连贯性的噩梦。
For Alicia, Wardrobe had eight changes. And Jenna, you and I love tracking things. Well, guess who else loves tracking things? Alicia. Kelly Cantley. Oh boy. Kelly Cantley. She listed off all of the things that they would have to track over weight loss one and two. I loved it so much. I wrote it down and I began to track it as well. Number
对艾莉西亚来说，服装造型一共有八套换装。珍娜，你和我都很喜欢追踪各种细节。好吧，猜猜还有谁也喜欢追踪细节？艾莉西亚。凯莉·坎特利。哦天哪。凯莉·坎特利。她列举了在《减肥》（上下集）中他们必须追踪的所有事情。我太喜欢了。我把它写了下来，我也开始追踪了。第一
one, eight wardrobe changes. Number two, eight set dressings of the main office bullpen. Number three, was it raining or not raining outside the windows, depending on the scene? Number four, they had three different goatee beards on Michael Ryan and Dwight. Number five, Meredith's sunburned face. We'll get to that. Number six, the dry erase board with everyone's weight loss stats. 7. The fruit flies. 8. The rotting of fruit.
项，八套服装造型。第二项，主办公室大开间内的八种布景。第三项，根据场景的不同，窗外是在下雨还是没下雨。第四项，迈克尔、瑞恩和德怀特蓄了三种不同的山羊胡。第五项，梅瑞狄斯晒伤的脸。我们待会儿会聊到这个。第六项，写着每个人减肥数据的干擦白板。第七项，果蝇。第八项，水果腐烂的过程。
Wow! That's what they were keeping track of! So many things! And then lastly, this episode was a huge challenge for the editing department. Do you remember in Goodbye Toby how I had the script, I had the shooting draft, and I kept telling you how the scenes were all rearranged differently for the episode that actually aired? Yeah. Well, Jake shared in the commentary that Greg and the writers were very used to being able to just move scenes around and kind of change how the episode would take shape. And they could not do that
哇！原来他们一直在追踪这些！有这么多事情！最后，这一集对剪辑部门来说是一个巨大的挑战。还记得在《托比离职》那一集里，我拿着剧本，我拿着拍摄初稿，我一直告诉你们，为了最终播出的剧集，场景是如何被全部重新排列组合的吗？记得。好吧，杰克在评论音轨中分享说，格雷格和编剧们非常习惯于直接把场景挪来挪去，以此改变剧集的成型方式。但他们做不到
in this episode because it's week to week and everything progresses week to week within one episode. And you can't move around that story. No, and our clothes are changing, right? Yes. Like you'd notice, but there is, I saw a little flub. Yes. Well, you'll have to bring that up. And they also address, and I'll bring this up when it happens, a character that they had to keep digitally changing their shirt. What?
在这一集里不能这么做，因为它是按周推进的，而且在一集之内，一切都是一周一周往前发展的。你没法打乱那个故事。没错，我们的衣服也在变，对吧？是的。就像你会注意到的，不过确实有，我看到一个小失误。没错。好吧，你得把这个提出来。他们还提到过——等它发生时我会提出来的——有一个角色的衬衫他们必须一直通过数字技术进行修改。什么？
Yes. I'll share when we get to the moment. Angela, I think you need to do fast facts more often, because that is possibly one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done. I'm giving you fast fact number three from now on. Oh, I bet you are. Thanks.
对。等我们到那个情节时我再分享。安吉拉，我觉得你以后应该多来做速查趣闻，因为这可能是我做过的最喜欢的速查趣闻之一。从今以后这部分归你了。噢，我敢说肯定是这样。谢谢。
I know you guys fast facts are really hard. Fast facts are really hard. Jenna created fast facts for herself and then was like, Angela, these dang fast facts. I wish every week the crew did the DVD commentary is what I wish because it's the best commentary. It was the most insightful, interesting, the best background trivia. Fast Fact 3 was easy because of our crew's commentary. I cannot wait to watch that payoff as we break down this episode.
我知道大家觉得速查趣闻很难。速查趣闻确实很难。珍娜为自己创作了速查趣闻，然后就感叹说：安吉拉，这些该死的速查趣闻啊。我真希望每周都是剧组来做DVD评论音轨，因为这真的是最棒的评论。它信息量最丰富、最有趣，包含了最好的背景冷知识。由于我们剧组的评论音轨，第三条速查趣闻变得非常容易。我迫不及待地想在剖析这一集时看看这些幕后成果了。
Let's take a break. Shocker, I need to go to the bathroom. You know, we've had a big morning. It was a reunion. We both drank lots of beverages. All right, we're going to go to the restroom. We'll be right back. All right. Well, we are back. Everyone is in the conference room. They are having a feast. I mean, there is a buffet of food happening here.
我们休息一下。不出所料，我要去趟洗手间。你知道的，我们今天上午经历了一场盛会。这是一次重聚。我们俩都喝了好多饮料。好吧，我们要去洗手间。马上回来。好吧。我们回来了。大家都聚集在会议室里。他们在吃大餐。我的意思是，这里正在举办一场自助大餐。
Yeah, well, Michael tells everyone they better eat up because it's their last meal. They're going to start this weight loss competition, but first they're trying to bulk up. So that when they lose weight, the number is big. There's a big difference, right? Yes, exactly. Dwight has also told people they can't even use the bathroom. You're going to have to hold it. They want maximum poundage on the scale. And the stakes are high because Michael explains that this is a corporate weight loss challenge and the branch that loses the most weight
是的，麦克告诉大家最好赶快吃，因为这是他们的最后一餐。他们要开始减肥比赛了，但首先他们得增肥。这样等他们减肥时，数字才会好看。这差别很大，对吧？对，完全正确。德怀特还告诉大家甚至不准上厕所。你们得憋着。他们想在秤上称出最大磅数。而且赌注很高，因为麦克解释说这是一场公司减肥挑战赛，减掉最多重量的分公司
wins three whole extra vacation days. Everyone's excited. Yeah. I paused and I went frame by frame and I made a list of all the food I could see. I love this. This is reminding me a little bit of my pizza by Alfredo moment. Is it going to be 10 minutes? No, there's not that much food.
就能赢得整整三天额外的假期。大家都兴奋极了。对。我暂停了视频，一帧一帧地看，列出了我能看到的所有食物。我喜欢这个。这让我想起了一点我的“阿尔弗雷德披萨”时刻。会持续10分钟吗？不，没那么多食物。
Okay, let's hear it. All right. There is a chocolate fondue fountain. There is a cheese fondue fountain. There are marshmallows, fried chicken, ribs, maybe some waffles, cornbread muffins, donuts, lots of soda, mac and cheese, dumplings. I swear someone has mashed potatoes and gravy on their plate. And then Jim has some strawberries on his plate, probably for the chocolate fountain.
好吧，说来听听。好的。有一个巧克力火锅喷泉。有一个奶酪火锅喷泉。有棉花糖、炸鸡、排骨，也许还有华夫饼、玉米面包松饼、甜甜圈，大量的苏打水、通心粉奶酪、饺子。我发誓有人盘子里装了土豆泥和肉汁。然后吉姆盘子里有一些草莓，可能是为了巧克力火锅。
But I was surprised to spot a bit of healthy food. Not surprised to see it on John Krasinski's plate, however. He was such a healthy eater. He was. Jenna, do you know what I remember about this scene? What? How funky that cheese got. Yeah. It got real smelly. Yeah. Kelly shares on the DVD that they could only keep that cheese melted for three hours.
但我很惊讶能看到一点健康的食物。不过出现在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的盘子里一点也不奇怪。他一直是个健康饮食者。他是。珍娜，你知道我对这场戏印象最深的是什么吗？什么？那奶酪变得多恶心。对。变得超级臭。对。凯莉在DVD里分享说，他们只能让那奶酪融化三个小时。
It would start to coagulate from whatever. It got so gross. I mean, that really makes me think twice about any cheese fondue fountain. The fountain food. I might be done with fountain food. When I was in college, I had a boyfriend and we read that there was like this protein shake company that was gonna give a $10,000 prize to whoever lost the most weight and like gained the most muscle by like using their protein shake.
不管怎样，它开始凝固了。变得超级恶心。我是说，这真的让我对任何奶酪火锅喷泉都三思而后行。喷泉食物。我可能再也不吃喷泉食物了。我上大学时有个男朋友，我们看到有一家蛋白质奶昔公司要给在规定时间内减掉最多体重、通过使用他们的蛋白质奶昔获得最多肌肉的人一万美元的奖金。
Right, so the idea is to like get healthy, lose weight, and here's your incentive as a bunch of money or something. Yeah, so we entered. You and your boyfriend? Yeah. You did the shake challenge? We did. Here's the thing, we did the same thing.
对，所以主意就是变得健康、减肥，而给你的奖励是一大笔钱之类的。对，所以我们参加了。你和你的男朋友？对。你们参加了奶昔挑战赛？我们参加了。是这样的，我们做了同样的事。
We're like in the week before. You who carved up? We did, we ate a bunch of food. I probably gained about five pounds. In one week. Yeah, because we just like ate pizza and burgers because we were like, this is great. I mean, we'll start out with more weight and then we'll lose it all and more.
我们就像在比赛前一周。你们怎么吃撑的？我们是这样的，我们吃了一堆食物。我大概胖了五斤。在一周内。对，因为我们只是吃披萨和汉堡，因为我们觉得，这太棒了。我的意思是，我们先带着更多的体重开始，然后再把它们全减掉，甚至减掉更多。
And we'll win ten thousand dollars. Yeah. I mean, we took pictures of ourselves. I still have it. Oh, no. I mean, somewhere I have it. I know because I was cleaning out some old photo albums and I found it. And it jogged this memory. You had to prove the day, you know, of the weight loss start. So you had to hold up that day's newspaper. I mean,
然后我们就能赢得一万美元。对。我的意思是，我们拍了照片。我还留着。哦，不。我是说，某个地方我还有。我知道，因为我在清理一些旧相册时发现了它。它唤醒了这段记忆。你必须证明日期，你知道的，也就是减肥开始的那天。所以你必须举起当天的报纸。我的意思是，
like a hostage photo. Oh my God. So I've got this picture of myself. This was before you could Instagram. Now you can insta-story or Instagram and it's a timestamp, but back then you had to hold up like a newspaper. Yeah. And take it with a regular old camera. I'm in like a sports bra and some like sport shorts. Mm-hmm. And I'm holding up a newspaper. And I will tell you what, not only did we not win, I did not lose any of the weight. That you gained carb loading?
就像人质照片一样。天哪。所以我有一张自己的照片。这还是在你可以用Instagram之前。现在你可以发快拍或Instagram，那是有时间戳的，但在当时，你得举起一张报纸。对。然后用一台老式相机拍。我穿着运动胸罩和一些运动短裤。嗯哼。我手里举着报纸。我得告诉你们，我们不仅没赢，我连一斤都没瘦。你通过碳水增重长胖的那些？
That's right. After the eight weeks, I mean, we gave up so quickly. We were all in for the first week of the fitness weeks. I mean, we gave up so quickly. We were all in for the first week of the fitness challenge. And then all that happened was from all of this is that I gained five pounds and then I held up a newspaper. So that memory came flooding back as I was watching us in this conference room scene. So Stanley, Meredith, and Creed have plans for their leftovers. Stanley really wants to take some of these dumplings home,
没错。八周之后，我是说，我们放弃得太快了。健身周的第一周我们是全力以赴的。我是说，我们放弃得太快了。健身周的第一周我们是全力以赴的。然后发生的一切就是，从这一切中我胖了五斤，然后我举着一份报纸。所以当我在会议室里看我们这场戏时，这段记忆一下子涌上心头。所以斯坦利、梅雷迪思和克里德对他们的剩菜有了计划。斯坦利真的很想把这些饺子带回家，
but Dwight is like, no, no, you cannot take any of this food home, we're eating healthy now. And he starts spraying what looks like an insect repellent all over all of the food. We had a fan question from Chelsea B, Alice R, and Henry F. What was in the bottle that Dwight is spraying on the food? Well, guess who knows? You?
但德怀特说，不，不，你们不能把这些食物带回家，我们现在吃得很健康。然后他开始在所有的食物上喷一种看起来像杀虫剂的东西。我们收到了来自切尔西·B、爱丽丝·R和亨利·F的粉丝提问。德怀特喷在食物上的瓶子里是什么？好吧，猜猜谁知道？你？
Me, thanks to our crew. It was not real bug spray, of course. This was a prop bottle that Phil Shea had designed. He had this made, and it was full of aerosol water. Oh. So he was just spraying water. You know, I assumed that's what it was, but it didn't look like water.
我，多亏了我们的剧组。当然不是真的杀虫剂。这是一个菲尔·谢伊设计的道具瓶。他让人做了这个，里面装满了气溶胶水。哦。所以他只是在喷水。你知道的，我以为那就是水，但看起来不像水。
I mean, it looks so real. I thought it looked real and I thought everyone's reactions were really good. Great acting folks, you sold it. Well, now the gang is gonna go down to the warehouse. They're gonna weigh in. Yes, and Jenna gang is going to go down to the warehouse. They're going to weigh in. Yes. And Jenna, at one minute, five seconds, there is a great shot of the big scale that we're
我是说，看起来太真实了。我觉得看起来很真实，而且我觉得大家的反应真的很棒。演技真棒各位，你们演得太到位了。好吧，现在大家要下到仓库去了。他们要过秤了。是的，珍娜，大家要下到仓库去了。他们要过秤了。是的。珍娜，在1分5秒时，有一个很棒的大秤镜头，我们
all going to get weighed on. And I have a prop, a breakdown. Give it to me. Okay. That scale was custom made by Rice Lake Weighing Systems. They made it specific to our requests and they were able to program the little computer screen with whatever the writers wanted them to put on it, right? It was like part of the joke. Our weight, that was all like
所有人都要在上面过秤。我有一个道具幕后剖析。快告诉我。好的。那个秤是由赖斯湖称重系统公司定制的。他们根据我们的要求专门制造了它，并且能够根据编剧的要求在小电脑屏幕上编程任何他们想放上去的东西，对吧？这就像是个笑话的一部分。我们的体重，那全都是
a writer's joke. My mind is being blown right now that that was not a real scale. No, the scale didn't exist. It was made just for us. And Rice Lake Wings System didn't ask for any credit or any company plug. They were huge fans of the show. And they did come to set the day we filmed this. And everyone on our crew said they were so nice. And after this episode aired, that scale stayed in the warehouse as part of the warehouse set. That I remember. Mm-hmm. Now, during this weigh-in, Angela, what's up with Meredith's face? Did you notice? Her face is all red. We got a lot of mail about it. They want to know what's going on. Was there a storyline that was cut or something?
编剧的笑话。我简直惊呆了，那居然不是个真的秤。不，那个秤根本不存在。那是专门为我们制作的。而且赖斯湖称重系统公司没有要求任何鸣谢或公司植入。他们是节目的超级粉丝。他们确实在我们拍摄的那天来到了片场。我们剧组的所有人都说他们人太好了。在这集播出后，那个秤作为仓库布景的一部分留在了仓库里。我记得。嗯哼。现在，在这次过秤期间，安吉拉，梅雷迪思的脸怎么了？你注意到了吗？她的脸全红了。我们收到了很多关于这事的邮件。他们想知道是怎么回事。是不是有一条剧情线被剪掉了还是怎么的？
Oh, yes. I want you guys to know, I took a photo of Kate's face as Meredith looking like that, and I texted it to Kate last night, and I said, Kate, you know what? you should win team player award for the run of the office. Cause her character was always getting into some kind of mishap,
哦，是的。我想让你们知道，我拍了一张凯特作为梅雷迪思顶着那张脸的照片，昨晚我把它发给了凯特，我说，凯特，你知道吗？在整部办公室的故事里，你应该赢得团队合作奖。因为她的角色总是陷入各种各样的倒霉事，
which resulted in Kate being in the hair and makeup trailer forever, right? Yeah. And here was the storyline and it's shared in the deleted scenes. Meredith gets severely sunburned. And here is her explanation. Sam, can you play the clip?
这导致凯特永远都要待在发型和化妆车里，对吧？对。这就是剧情线，它在删减片段里分享了。梅雷迪思严重晒伤了。这是她的解释。萨姆，你能播放一下这个片段吗？
These guys took me out in a fishing boat. I don't think I caught anything. Hello, hello. Hey. Your face is almost back to normal. One more kid calls me Hellboy. I swear to God. Oh, you wish.
这几个家伙带我坐渔船出去了。我想我什么都没钓到。哈喽，哈喽。嘿。你的脸几乎快恢复正常了。再有一个小屁孩叫我地狱男爵。我发誓。哦，你希望呢。
Hellboy's a hero. Oh, wow. Yeah, she's a hero. Oh, wow. Yeah, she went out on a boat, got super, super sunburned. And this was something they had to watch in continuity of which stage of the sunburn was her face at. Then the whole storyline got deleted, but they couldn't take out Kate's face. You know what I mean?
地狱男爵是个英雄。哦，哇。对，她是英雄。哦，哇。对，她出海坐船，被晒得超级超级严重。这是他们在连戏时必须注意的事情，看看她的脸处于晒伤的哪个阶段。然后整条剧情线都被删掉了，但他们没办法把凯特脸上的镜头删掉。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, yeah. So they just had to leave it in. And Kate said the day after the show aired, Steve came up to her on set and was like, you know what Kate, I still thought it was funny. You know, I kind of love that Meredith has this mystery about her, that she has this whole other life we don't even need to explain. And Kate said it made her feel so good that Steve was so thoughtful to come over and say that. Yeah, that was hard when you had a storyline and then you'd watch the episode. They wouldn't warn you a lot of the times.
对，对。所以他们只能保留这个镜头。凯特说节目播出的第二天，史蒂夫在片场走到她面前说，你知道吗，凯特，我还是觉得那挺搞笑的。你知道的，我其实挺喜欢梅雷迪思身上这种神秘感的，她有着我们甚至不需要解释的另一面生活。凯特说史蒂夫特意走过来这么说，让她感觉太棒了。对，当你有一条剧情线，然后你看到播出的剧集时，那种感觉真挺难受的。很多时候他们不会提前警告你。
You'd just watch the episode and it was gone. Yeah. And you know, with supporting cast, we were often, you know, in the B or C story and those really got moved around a lot. Yeah. And trimmed and edited and it did happen. But Kate, man, such a good sport. Wow.
你就只是看播出的剧集，然后它就没了。对。而且你知道的，对于配角演员来说，我们经常，你知道的，处在B线或C线剧情中，那些剧情确实经常被大幅调动。对。被删减和编辑，这确实发生了。但凯特，天哪，真是太有体育精神了。哇。
Guys, also in this scene, Michael throws Pam off the scale because she's going to go away to art school. So he doesn't want her extra poundage. Now they've already weighed in, and then Pam gets off the scale and a new weight is displayed. So embarrassing. Everyone is clocking this number change.
各位，同样在这场戏里，麦克把潘从秤上推开，因为她要去艺术学校了。所以他不想要她身上多余的重量。现在他们已经过完秤了，然后潘从秤上下来，显示出了一个新的体重。太尴尬了。所有人都注意到了这个数字的变化。
Yeah. We got some fan mail from Kim C. who said, during the group weigh-in, it becomes clear that Pam weighs 126 pounds. Jenna, did the writers consult you about your actual weight when they added this fact, or did they just guess how much they thought you might weigh? And were you comfortable with sharing this speculation
对。我们收到了金·C发来的一些粉丝邮件，上面说，在集体过秤期间，很明显潘的体重是126磅。珍娜，当编剧们加上这个事实时，他们有向你咨询你的实际体重吗，还是他们只是盲目猜测你可能有多重？你对于分享关于你体重的这种猜测觉得自在吗？
about your weight? Well, I'll tell you guys, actually in the script, the original table draft, Pam weighed 145 pounds. And I said, you guys, this is, I feel like a weird thing for me to split hairs about, but I don't weigh 145 pounds. It's not accurate, why don't you just put my real weight, which at the time was 126 pounds. I don't weigh 126 pounds anymore, but at the time that was my weight and so they changed it. But yeah, when they speculated about my weight, they
好吧，我告诉你们，实际上在剧本中，最初的剧本围读草案里，潘的体重是145磅。我说，各位，这，我觉得我为了这个斤斤计较有点奇怪，但我没有145磅重。这不准确，你们为什么不直接写我真实的体重，当时是126磅。我现在没有126磅了，但当时那是我的体重，所以他们改了。但是，是的，当他们猜测我的体重时，他们
put me at 145 and I just, I don't know, I just corrected it. I thought it should be correct. I have it should be correct. I have no problem with that. Well, Jenna, that scene made me laugh just because your performance, your reaction, you watch everyone doing the math and you're just standing there. Yeah.
把我写成了145磅，我只是，我不知道，我只是纠正了它。我觉得这应该是准确的。我觉得这应该准确。我对此没有任何意见。好吧，珍娜，那场戏把我逗笑了，纯粹是因为你的表演，你的反应，你看着大家都在算数学，而你只是站在那里。对。
And it was very funny the way you played that moment. Now it's week two of their weight loss contest. Oscar and Andy arrive, they're gonna hold the elevator for Stanley. And Stanley says he forgot something and then he takes the stairs without them knowing. And he has a great talking head where he shares that he's been losing weight on his own. And he just noticed some of your speed and fire that he's lost a little bit of his pick up and go. And he's doing this for himself. Yes. And in this talking head, he shows an old photo of himself. Well, we got some mail
而且你处理那一刻的方式非常搞笑。现在是他们减肥比赛的第二周。奥斯卡和安迪到了，他们要帮斯坦利按住电梯。斯坦利说他忘带了东西，然后在他们不知情的情况下走楼梯了。他有一个很棒的单人访谈，在其中他分享说他一直在靠自己减肥。他只是注意到自己失去了一些速度和活力，他有点失去那种说走就走的冲劲了。他是在为自己这么做。是的。在这个单人访谈中，他展示了一张自己年轻时的照片。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件
about that. People wanted to know, what is this picture? Is this from Leslie David Baker's real life? Yes. Is this young Leslie in this photo? It is young Leslie in the photo. Oh my gosh. I texted Leslie and he gave me all the info. Oh, let's hear it. It's a Photoshop picture. He does not know any of the other people in the picture.
关于这个。人们想知道，这张照片是什么？这是莱斯利·大卫·贝克现实生活中的照片吗？是的。照片里这是年轻的莱斯利吗？照片里确实是年轻的莱斯利。天哪。我给莱斯利发了信息，他把所有信息都告诉我了。哦，快说来听听。这是一张P图。他不认识照片里的任何其他人。
Got it. They Photoshopped him into it using one of his old prom photos. Oh, Leslie, I love that. Yeah. Well, they're really taking this whole get healthy fitness thing seriously. Holly is running a yoga class in the conference room.
明白了。他们用他的一张旧毕业舞会照片把他P进去了。哦，莱斯利，我太喜欢了。好吧，他们真的很认真地对待这个保持健康的健身事情。霍莉正在会议室里上瑜伽课。
I only saw three people in attendance, Creed, Kelly, and Michael. I didn't see anyone else. Oh. Yeah. And then Michael is so excited. He runs up to Jim as Jim is going into the bathroom and is like, did you see Holly's butt?
我只看到三个人参加，克里德、凯莉和麦克。我没看到其他人。哦。对。然后麦克兴奋极了。当吉姆正要进卫生间时，他跑向吉姆，说道：“你看到霍莉的屁股了吗？”
And Jim's like, no, you know why? Because we don't do that. Friends don't talk about other friends' butts, right? And Jim is really trying to get Michael to have a little growth, right? And he's like, what have you learned about her? And Michael says, I learned that she broke her left leg twice in one year. I learned that she's allergic to sesame seeds. I learned that she has read Lonesome Dove three times and that her butt refuses to quit.
吉姆说：“没有，你知道为什么吗？因为我们不那样做。朋友不会谈论其他朋友的屁股，对吧？”吉姆真的在试图让麦克有一点成长，对吧？然后他说：“你对她有什么了解？”麦克说：“我了解到她一年内左腿骨折过两次。我了解到她对芝麻过敏。我了解到她把《没人的牧场》读了三遍，而且她的屁股坚持不懈。”
And Jim's like, I give up. Little sidebar moment for you. What's that? Lonesome Dove was written by Larry McMurtry, who is from my hometown of Archer City, Texas. Yes. And I knew Larry and I know his family and Larry was this amazing prolific writer.
吉姆说：“我放弃了。”给你们说个小插曲。什么？《没人的牧场》是拉里·麦克默特里写的，他来自我的家乡德克萨斯州阿彻城。是的。我认识拉里，我也认识他的家 人，拉里是一位了不起的高产作家。
I got so excited just to see one of his pieces of work mentioned on the office, knowing that I grew up going to his bookstore. That is so cool. Love it. You guys gotta know, there's only like 1800 people in Archer City, so everybody knows everybody. We got some fan mail from Brittany.
仅仅在《办公室》里看到他的作品被提及，我就感到非常兴奋，因为我知道我从小就是去他的书店长大的。太酷了。太喜欢了。你们得知道，阿彻城只有大约1800人，所以每个人都认识每个人。我们收到了布兰妮发来的一封粉丝邮件。
Uh-huh. She did her own little mini deep dive. On? On sesame seed allergies. Oh! Yeah. She did a deep dive? She did.
嗯哼。她做了自己的微型深度剖析。关于什么？关于芝麻过敏。哦！是的。她做了一次深度剖析？她做了。
She said that she would like us to know that sesame seed allergies are actually the ninth most common type of food allergy. I did not know that. Do you have any allergies? I do. I'm allergic to sweet potatoes. Crazy. Yeah.
她说她希望我们知道芝麻过敏实际上是第九最常见的食物过敏类型。我以前不知道这个。你有什么过敏症吗？我有。我对红薯过敏。太疯狂了。对。
I found that out late in life because my mom would only make sweet potatoes at Thanksgiving, and I'm sorry, mom, but they always looked really gross to me, so I just never even ate them. I don't know if I had some sort of like visceral kind of instinct that I shouldn't eat them. Like your body knew. Yeah, but I never ate them. And then my first Thanksgiving in Los Angeles,
我是在生活中比较晚的时候发现这一点的，因为我妈妈只在感恩节做红薯，对不起，妈妈，但它们在我看来总是超级恶心，所以我甚至从来不吃。我不知道我当时是不是有一种发自内心的直觉，觉得我不应该吃它们。就像你的身体知道一样。对，但我从来没吃过。然后我在洛杉矶过的第一个感恩节，
I couldn't go home, I couldn't afford it. So me and my friends, we had our own Thanksgiving, and someone brought some sweet potatoes that looked effing amazing. So I had some. The next day, I got super sick. I wrote it off. I had taken some of those sweet potatoes home as a leftover.
我没法回家，我负担不起机票。所以我和我的朋友们过了我们自己的感恩节，有人带来了看起来他妈的棒极了的红薯。所以我吃了一些。第二天，我病得超厉害。我没把这当回事。我把那些红薯打包了一些作为剩菜带回家了。
I ate them again, got super sick again. That's when the doctor was like, I think you should stop eating sweet potatoes. I got an allergy test, and I am allergic to sweet potatoes. My daughter has a mild allergy to dairy. But you can really tell like if she's had ice cream and stuff, she'll get really stuffy. Oh, yeah. A lot of people have like a lactose intolerance that causes like some kind of like diarrhea.
我又吃了一次，结果又病得超厉害。就在那时，医生说：“我觉得你真该别吃红薯了。”我做了过敏测试，我确实对红薯过敏。我女儿对乳制品有轻微过敏。但你真的能看出她是不是吃了冰淇淋之类的东西，她会变得鼻塞得很厉害。哦，对。很多人都有乳糖不耐受，会引起某种腹泻。
Well, this is our spininoff podcast. It's called What Foods Do To You? Body Fluids and Other Stories. I mean, since we're on the subject of milk and stuff, I just want to say, guys, don't give milk to cats. Oh, yeah, it makes them sick. Yeah, it's like a thing that's been passed down in these cartoons forever. You give cats a dish of milk. They are Allergic to the dairy and milk don't get it to them. Can I add to your milk with cats thing? Oh, yeah
好吧，这是我们的衍生播客。它叫《食物对你做了什么？体液与其他故事》。既然我们聊到了牛奶之类的话题，我只想说，各位，不要给猫喂牛奶。哦，对，那会让他们生病。对，这是在这些动画片里流传了很久的事情。你给猫一盘牛奶。它们对乳制品和牛奶过敏，不要给它们喝。我能补充一下你关于猫和牛奶的观点吗？哦，对。
Don't give bread to ducks. Oh Bread to ducks, you know what you can give them what peas Oh and birdseed. Okay More food talk for you. Three minutes, 49 seconds. Dwight is replacing the junk food in the vending machine with fruit. Now, Kelly Cantley said, this scene, which I timed its seven seconds, took them one hour to shoot.
不要给鸭子喂面包。哦，鸭子吃面包，你知道你可以喂它们什么吗？豌豆。还有鸟食。好吧，接下来还有更多关于食物的话题。3分49秒。德怀特正在用水果替换自动售货机里的垃圾食品。现在，凯莉·坎特利说，这个场景我掐秒算了一下是七秒钟，他们花了一个小时才拍完。
Because of the like banging the fruit in with the hammer? Just all of it, ripping everything out, resetting it, putting the fruit in. It took them an hour to do a seven second scene. Coming up as a really awkward scene in so many ways. So many. Oscar is gonna offer to set Holly up with his yoga instructor.
因为要用锤子把水果砸进去吗？所有这一切，把所有东西扯下来，重置，把水果放进去。他们花了一个小时来拍一个七秒钟的场景。接下来是一个在很多方面都超级尴尬的场景。超级尴尬。奥斯卡要主动提出把霍莉介绍给他的瑜伽教练。
Mm-hmm. I feel like that was awkward number one. I mean, it's jumping in real quick being matchmaker. Yeah. I always feel like you wait for someone to ask you to set them up because there are so many assumptions you're making about their life and their preferences when you offer to set them up. Right? Yeah. I know, just- Also, how long has he known her? Have they hung out? Like, what does he know about Holly, right?
嗯哼。我觉得这是第一号尴尬。我的意思是，当红娘跳得太快了。对。我总觉得你会等别人主动要求你给他们牵线搭桥，因为当你主动提出来时，你对他们的生活和偏好做了太多的假设。对吧？对。我知道，只是——还有，他认识她多久了？他们一起出去玩过吗？比如，他对霍莉了解多少，对吧？
Right. This takes us to front reception and Jim is making sure Pam is all packed for New York. He's holding a box of her items she's gonna take with her. Did you notice at four minutes, 47 seconds, what is in the box that is so important? It's gotta travel to New York City with Pam.
对。这把我们带到了前台接待处，吉姆正在确认潘已经把去纽约的东西都收拾好了。他拿着一盒她要随身带走的物品。你有没有注意到在4分47秒时，箱子里有什么东西如此重要？它必须和潘一起去纽约市。
Apparently, her weird spindly, plasticky desk decoration. She can't live without it. I put the multicolored sphere bobble thing. Yeah, we've talked about it on the podcast before. I get that maybe she needed to clear her desk for whoever's filling in for her. Just leave the box. Put it in a storeroom and get it out when you get back. There's nothing in that box you need at Pratt, Pam. Nothing.
显然，是她那个奇怪的、细长的、塑料质感的桌上装饰品。她没有它就活不下去了。我放了那个多色球体磁力摆件。对，我们以前在播客里讨论过。我能理解她可能需要为接替她的人腾出办公桌。那就把箱子留下。把它放进储藏室，等你回来时再拿出来。那个箱子里没有什么东西是你去普瑞特艺术学院必须带的，潘。什么都没有。
But Pam has a talking head. It's super cute. I loved doing it where I say, what up 212? I hate to tell you, Pam, the area code for Pratt, which is located in Brooklyn, is 718. No, Pam. But it's okay. You're trying to be all New Yorkie.
但潘有一个单人访谈。超级可爱。我演得很开心，我说：“最近怎么样212？”我很不想告诉你，潘，普瑞特艺术学院位于布鲁克林，它的区号是718。不，潘。但没关系。你只是想表现得很像个纽约客。
You're trying to be cool. Yeah, that's the Manhattan area code. Well, at five minutes, 13 seconds, there's gonna be a storyline that starts, which is Andy and Angela wedding planning. There's lots of delicious stuff. There's lots more in deleted scenes. All of this wedding planning is just absolutely stressing
你只是想显得很酷。对，那是曼哈顿的区号。好吧，在5分13秒时，将有一条剧情线开始，那就是安迪和安吉拉筹备婚礼。这里有很多好玩的东西。删减片段里还有更多。所有这些筹备婚礼的事简直把安吉拉
Angela out and making her more and more irritated at Andy. This is how he walks up to her. Ange, Ella, Ella, Ella, Ella, under my Anderella, Ella, Ella, Ella, eh, eh, what what I loved it so much that's how they're starting their conversation and he's excited he says every little boy fantasizes about his fairy tale wedding and ding ding ding this is when they had to go in and digitally change his shirt and tie in post-production because the writers wanted
折磨得压力山大，让她对安迪越来越恼火。他是这样走向她的：安杰，拉，拉，拉，拉，在我的安杰拉拉拉拉拉下面，え，え，什么什么我太喜欢了，他们就是这样开始对话的，他很兴奋地说，每个小男孩都幻想过自己的童话婚礼，叮叮叮，这就是他们在后期制作中不得不进去对他的衬衫和领带进行数字修改的时候，因为编剧们想要
to move this talking head here. It had been in a different place in the story. His tie and his shirt are digital. Because they had to make it match the scene with Angela. That's right. My mind is blown. Oh yeah, they had to change all of that in post so they could move this talking head up.
把这个单人访谈移到这里。它在故事里原本在不同的地方。他的领带和衬衫是数码合成的。因为他们必须让它和安吉拉的场景相匹配。没错。我惊呆了。哦，对，他们不得不在后期修改所有这些，以便把这个单人访谈提上来。
Well, in the scene with Angela, he is suggesting that they get married at the Breakers in Rhode Island, this famous estate. Angela doesn't like it. He said this is really important to his family because this is where his parents decided not to get divorced. How romantic. Yes, that's where you want to get married. I looked this place up. It was built back in 1893 as a summer home. Not even a main residence. It was built by the Vanderbilt family. It cost $7 million to build back then. Back then?
好吧，在和安吉拉的场景中，他建议他们在罗德岛的“破坏者”庄园结婚，这是一个著名的庄园。安吉拉不喜欢。他说这对他的家族非常重要，因为这是他父母决定不离婚的地方。多浪漫啊。是的，这就是你想要结婚的地方。我查了一下这个地方。它建于1893年，作为避暑别墅。甚至不是主要住所。它是范德比尔特家族建造的。当时建造它花费了700万美元。当时？
Back then. It took two years. Is it massive? Yeah. There are 70 rooms in the house. The Great Hall. 70 rooms for their summer residence. Right, and the Great Hall has 45-foot ceilings. There's a gold room. Okay. That was actually built in Europe and then shipped to the United States and reassembled in Newport. and then shipped to the United States and reassembled in Newport.
当时。它花了两年时间。它很大吗？对。房子里有70个房间。大厅。作为避暑住所就有70个房间。对，大厅有45英尺高的天花板。还有一个黄金屋。好的。那实际上是在欧洲建造的，然后运到美国，在纽波特重新组装。然后运到美国，在纽波特重新组装。
Good Lord. It is estimated to be worth $150 million today. That one room? No, the whole house. Oh. I know. I see how you went there because of the way I structured that.
天哪。据估计，今天它的价值高达1.5亿美元。就那一个房间？不，整栋房子。哦。我懂了。我知道你为什么会这么想，因为我刚才说话的结构就是那样。
Oh my gosh. So. $150 million? Yeah. It now belongs to the Preservation Society of Newport County. It is available for tours. It gets about 300,000 visitors annually.
我的天呐。所以，1.5亿美元？对。它现在属于纽波特县历史保护协会。它对外开放参观。它每年大约吸引30万名游客。
But get this, great grandchildren still live there on the third floor during the summer. Oh my god. But you can't tour their private residence area when you tour the house. This is like going to Buckingham Palace. I always wonder about that. Like you live there, but there's tours.
但你听说了吗，曾孙辈们夏天仍然住在三楼。我的天。但当你参观这座房子时，你不能参观他们的私人住所区。这就像去白金汉宫一样。我总是很好奇这一点。就像你住在那里，但还有人在参观。
Yeah, what is that? I don't know. 70 rooms, maybe you don't even know. Are you not giving tours of your home, Angela, to tourists while you live there? You're welcome to come over. The whole bathroom, you have to jiggle the handle. It's a double flusher.
对，那是什么情况？我不知道。70个房间，也许你根本不知道。安吉拉，你住在自己的家里，不给游客参观，对吧？欢迎你随时过来。整个浴室，你得晃晃把手。那是双冲水马桶。
It doesn't quite do it the first time. Well, all of this wedding planning stresses Angela out and she immediately pages Dwight. And they rendezvous in the warehouse. Angela comes out of the little warehouse. I don't even know what you call it. Storage room where they meet up. And she says, look, that was the last time.
第一次往往冲不干净。好吧，所有这些婚礼筹备工作让安吉拉压力山大，她立刻用寻呼机呼叫了德怀特。他们在仓库里碰面。安吉拉从那个小仓库里走了出来。我甚至不知道该怎么称呼它。他们碰头的储藏室。她说，听着，那是最后一次。
I have a fiance I very much like. All right, Jenna, there are deleted scenes that throughout weight loss one and two really show Angela struggling between wanting to be excited for the wedding and also that Andy is driving her crazy. And then she runs to Dwight. It's sort of this love triangle. And the documentary crew clearly decided to ask her about it. And here was her response. It's in the deleted scenes. No, I'm not cheating on anybody. I have one fiance and I have physical relations with
我有一个我很喜欢的未婚夫。好吧，詹娜，有一些被删减的片段，在《减肥（上下集）》中真正展现了安吉拉内心的挣扎：她既想为婚礼感到兴奋，又觉得安迪快把她逼疯了。然后她去找了德怀特。这有点像三角恋。纪录片摄制组显然决定问她这件事。她的回应是这样的。它在删减片段里。不，我没有对任何人不忠。我有一个未婚夫，我和
one man. Hmm. She keeps it separate. One guy she'll marry and one guy for the shag. I guess Angela Martin is like, you know, once I'm at the aisle, it's done. Yeah, once I speak my vows, I'll stop sleeping with Dwight, but for right now, I am engaged. This is a period of, I guess, non-commitment,
一个男人发生肉体关系。嗯。她把他们分得很开。一个男人是她要嫁的，另一个男人是用来做爱的。我猜安吉拉·马丁就像是，你知道的，一旦我走上红毯，事情就定局了。对，一旦我宣誓结婚，我就不再和德怀特上床了，但目前为止，我还是订婚状态。这是一个，我猜是不承诺的时期，
but commitment, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how she's gonna deal with how bat-sh-t crazy Andy makes her once they're married. What will her outlet be? But yes, I thought that was interesting because there's that moment when she comes out of the storage room with Dwight where she sees the camera.
但又算是有承诺，我不知道。我不知道。我不知道等他们结了婚，她该怎么对付安迪那种把她逼得发疯的神经质。她的发泄口会是什么？不过是的，我觉得这很有趣，因为当她和德怀特从储藏室出来看到摄像机时，有那么一个瞬间。
Yeah. Right? And this talking head would have happened immediately after where they would have confronted her, which I thought was pretty ballsy for the documentary crew. Well, they need to follow up on these things. Yeah. Now we have a scene where Michael, through his window, sees that Pam is getting into her car.
对。对吧？而这个单人访谈就发生在紧接着的那一刻，他们当时质问了她，我觉得纪录片摄制组这胆子可真大。好吧，他们需要跟进这些事情。好了，现在我们看到一个场景，迈克尔透过他的窗户看到潘正在上车。
She's getting ready to drive to Pratt. And he has not said his goodbye. No, he hasn't. And I want you to know, I know whose office it was that he was in. Was it Paul Lieberstein's? No, it was Jen Saladas. Okay.
她正准备开车去普拉特艺术学院。而他还没有跟她道别。不，他没有。我想让你知道，我知道他当时是在谁的办公室里。是保罗·利伯斯坦的吗？不，是珍·萨拉达斯的。好吧。
There you go. If you're curious, that's the writer's room that Michael was in. And poor Michael, he practically wipes out two flights of stairs trying to get to Pam so he could say goodbye. It's so funny. And he wrote her a poem, but he left it upstairs. It ends with the word seagulls. Here's what I have to say about this scene. Pam is going to drive to New York
这就对了。如果你好奇的话，迈克尔当时就是在那个编剧室里。可怜的迈克尔，为了追上潘以便跟她道别，他从两层楼梯上差点摔下来。太搞笑了。他还给她写了一首诗，但他把它忘在楼上了。诗的结尾是“海鸥”这个词。关于这个场景，我想说的是：潘居然要开车去纽约？
in a pencil skirt? Also, here was my question. Where's she going to park her car? There's nowhere to park your car in New York City. You have to pay for a parking spot. Well, she's going to Brooklyn. She's going to like a college campus. You think they have a spot for her? I think they do. Oh, OK. I think there's a campus parking lot. OK, OK, OK.
而且还穿着铅笔裙？另外，我的问题是：她要把车停在哪儿？纽约市根本没地方停车。你得付钱租停车位。好吧，她要去布鲁克林。她要去类似于大学校园的地方。你觉得他们会给她留个车位吗？我觉得会的。哦，好吧。我想校园里应该有停车场。好吧，好吧，好吧。
I'm not worried about that. I'm worried about why did she come into work even for a half day? Why didn't she change her clothes? She's going to arrive at Pratt in a pencil skirt and panty hose. Really? Really. Pam. I hope there's parking. Well, listen,
我不担心这个。我担心的是她为什么还要去上班，哪怕只上半天班？她为什么不换身衣服？她将穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜到达普拉特学院。真的吗？真的。潘。但愿有停车位。好吧，听着，
I wanted you to know, Randy Cordray shared that this parking lot scene took place on an incredibly hot day. It was like triple digit weather in Los Angeles. And, you know, Steve runs hot anyway, and he had to run into this scene and it was super hot in a suit. Well, Phil Shea found a cooling vest that Steve could wear under his suit to help keep him cool. It's the type of vest that marathon runners and athletes have. They use it to cool their body temperature down.
我想让你们知道，兰迪·科德雷透露，这场停车场戏拍摄于一个热得不可思议的日子。洛杉矶的天气简直有三位数（华氏度）。而且，你知道的，史蒂夫本来就容易出汗，他得跑进这个镜头里，穿着西装超级热。好吧，菲尔·谢伊找到了一种冷却背心，让史蒂夫穿在西装里面来保持凉爽。这是马拉松运动员和运动员穿的那种背心。他们用它来降低体温。
It has these little frozen gel packs, and Steve had that on under his suit. I've never heard of this thing, which makes sense to me because I would never seek it out. I would never think, how can I be colder? No, I would never. It's a whole thing. I Googled it. There's many different types of cooling vests that you can get. Athletes use them. Soldiers use them. I mean, you know, it's like a whole thing. You know what I do own what a warming vest I have a vest and you put little hot packs in it. Mm-hmm, and it keeps you warm I bought it so that I could watch my son play ice hockey outdoors. Yeah Well, we used to stuff those little hot pocket thingies. What do you call them? Not the food hot pockets
它有这些冰冻的小凝胶包，史蒂夫在西装里面就穿着这个。我从来没听说过这玩意儿，这很合理，因为我永远不会主动去找这种东西。我绝不会去想，我怎么才能更冷？不，我绝不会。这挺复杂的。我谷歌了一下。你可以买到很多不同类型的冷却背心。运动员会用。士兵会用。我的意思是，你知道的，这挺复杂的。你知道我有什么吗？一件保暖背心，我有一件背心，你可以把小暖贴放进去。嗯哼，它能让你保暖。我买它是为了看我儿子在户外打冰球。对。好吧，我们以前会在里面塞那些小热贴。它们叫什么来着？不是食品加热包。
What are they called? I love the idea of us having a vest filled with hot pockets though. Cause then if you get hungry, it's a snack as well. It keeps you warm and full. Listen, on the office, I had one skirt that had two little stitch pockets in the back and I had one little tiny stitch pocket in the front. They would give us those little hot pack things.
它们叫什么？不过我很喜欢我们穿一件塞满加热包的背心的想法。因为那样的话，如果你饿了，它也是一份零食。它能让你保暖又饱腹。听着，在《办公室》里，我有一条裙子，后面有两个小缝线口袋，前面有一个小小的缝线口袋。他们会给我们那些小热贴。
Little hand warmers? Little hand warmers. I would stick two in my shoes. I would stick one in that front, they would give us those little hot pack things. Little hand warmers. Little hand warmers. I would stick two in my shoes. I would stick one in that front pocket, two in my back pocket. I'd stick a few in my bra. Same, yeah, I remember that. Yeah, and if my sweater had pockets,
小暖手宝？小暖手宝。我会把两个塞进鞋子里。我会把一个塞在前口袋里，两个塞在后口袋里。我会在文胸里塞几个。一样，对，我记得。对，如果我的毛衣有口袋，
I'd stick them in there. I'd stick so many of those on my body when we were filming outside when it was cold. One time our camera operator, Matt Stone, was like, Ann, just don't take this the wrong way, but I can see lumps in your butt on camera. Like they don't look human, like human lumps. I was like, dang it.
我就会把它们塞进去。当我们在外面寒冷的天气里拍戏时，我在身上塞了好多那种东西。有一次我们的摄影师马特·石头说：“安，别误会我的意思，但我在镜头里能看到你屁股上有肿块。看起来不像人类的，就像不属于人类的肿块。”我说：“该死。”
And I had to take my little heater things out of my pockets. Well, I can't believe that they got a cooling vest and I'm glad they did. I am too. I thought that was so smart. Mm-hmm. Well, it's time for another weigh-in. Big announcement, they lost 31 pounds. Wow. Michael and Holly was so smart. Well, it's time for another weigh-in. Big announcement, they lost 31 pounds.
我不得不把我的小加热器从口袋里掏出来。好吧，我真不敢相信他们弄到了一件冷却背心，我很高兴他们这么做了。我也是。我觉得这太聪明了。嗯哼。好吧，又到了称体重的时候了。重大宣布，他们瘦了31磅。哇。迈克尔和霍莉太聪明了。好吧，又到了称体重的时候了。重大宣布，他们瘦了31磅。
Wow. Michael and Holly are so excited, they're going to do a wrap. It's the most adorable thing. Because they're so dorky and cute together. Well, a little wrap trivia is that they have about 10 minutes of them wrapping, even though the part that you see in the show was completely scripted,
哇。迈克尔和霍莉太兴奋了，他们要来一段说唱。这是最可爱的事情。因为他们在一起时既书呆子气又可爱。好吧，关于说唱的一个小花絮是，他们有大约10分钟的说唱素材，尽管你在剧中看到的那个部分完全是按剧本演的，
even down to Holly rubbing her jacket. Yeah, yeah, the wiki wiki what? All of that was scripted. All of that was scripted, but they did go on and on. And Amy Ryan gave an interview where she said this was her favorite scene to shoot because they had so much fun. The crew said the same thing. They said it was so much fun that those two just went off and that the chemistry was just so apparent.
甚至连霍莉揉她的夹克都写进去了。对，对，“wiki wiki what？”所有这些都是按剧本演的。所有这些都是按剧本演的，但他们确实说个没完。艾米·瑞安在一次采访中说，这是她最喜欢拍摄的一场戏，因为他们玩得太开心了。剧组也这么说。他们说太有趣了，这两个人直接即兴发挥，那种化学反应简直太明显了。
I think this was the scene when they were shooting when they realized, oh, yeah, these two, true love. Yeah. Well, now it's week three, and there is a new receptionist in town. Yes, Ronnie. Yeah, Ronnie, played by Dale Raoul. She has been in a ton of stuff.
我想这就是他们在拍摄时意识到“哦，是的，这两个人，是真爱”的那场戏。好吧，现在是第三周了，镇上迎来了一位新前台。是的，罗妮。是的，由黛尔·劳尔扮演的罗妮。她演过超级多的作品。
She was Maxine in True Blood. Oh, Maxine Fortenberry. I love True Blood. She was fantastic. Of course, you would know that. Yes. I have a crossover connection with Dale. Tell me. We were both on Fresh Off the Boat. Well, there you go.
她在《真爱如血》里演过玛克辛。哦，玛克辛·福滕伯里。我喜欢《真爱如血》。她太棒了。当然，你肯定知道这个。是的。我和黛尔有一个跨剧集的缘分。快告诉我。我们俩都演过《初来乍到》。好吧，原来是这样。
Not Monk, surprisingly, but Fresh Off the Boat. Well, she will come back in season six. This is not the last we're gonna see of Ronnie. Meanwhile, we're gonna see Pam in her first class. She looks so cute. She has like, I'm calling it the college ponytail. She wears this really cute ponytail at school. All right, the ponytail is the only thing
不是《神探阿蒙》，出人意料吧，而是《初来乍到》。好吧，她会在第六季回归。这并不是我们最后一次见到罗妮。与此同时，我们将看到潘的第一堂课。她看起来太可爱了。她扎着我称之为“大学马尾”的发型。她在学校扎着这个非常可爱的马尾辫。好吧，马尾辫是潘身上唯一可爱的地方。
that's cute about Pam. Are you kidding? I thought you looked so cute in all of your college scenes. Did you notice how young everyone else is in the class? Oh, you stop it. No, but this was a deliberate choice. Well, okay. Pam is in her late 20s.
你在开玩笑吗？我觉得你在所有的大学场景里都看起来太可爱了。你注意到班里其他人有多年轻了吗？哦，得了吧。不，但这是一个刻意的选择。好吧，好的。潘已经快三十岁了。
Do you like how immediately I like stand up for my best friend? I'm like, you stop it. You are beautiful. You look just as young as those other ones. That's right, and you are smart. Okay. Thank you. You're welcome.
你喜欢我立刻为我最好的朋友出头吗？我就像是在说：“你少来。你很漂亮。你看上去和那些人一样年轻。”没错，而且你很聪明。好吧。谢谢。不客气。
I want you to know I was not being down on myself. I was just pointing out a deliberate production choice. Pam is in her late 20s, and they made sure that everyone in this class, that the background performers were all much younger. They're just starting off in college, right? Pam's going back to school. And they did want to create this story for Pam that she is kind of, you know.
我想让你知道我并不是在贬低自己。我只是指出一个刻意的制作选择。潘已经快三十岁了，他们确保了班里的每个人，那些背景演员都年轻得多。他们才刚刚开始上大学，对吧？潘是重返校园。他们确实想为潘创造这样一个故事，即她有点像，你知道的。
Yeah. I don't know, what am I saying? What do they call it? A non-traditional student. There you go. Well, not only that, she's in the wrong class. The teacher who was played by Sandra Lowe, Professor Monahan.
是的。我不知道，我在说什么？他们怎么称呼它？非传统学生。这就对了。不仅如此，她还上错了课。由桑德拉·洛饰演的老师，莫纳汉教授。
She's got that zinger of a joke about Zaft Chancery, you know? Which, by the way, I read a Reddit thread where people were like, that doesn't apply. It's wrong. Oh, my. Well, Pam does not end up leaving the class. And we got some mail. People were like, Pam has been so good about standing up for herself. Why doesn't she just leave the class?
她讲了一个关于扎夫特·钱瑟里（Zaft Chancery）的绝妙笑话，你知道吗？顺便说一句，我读过一个红迪网（Reddit）帖子，人们在上面说，那根本不适用。那是错的。噢，天哪。好吧，潘并没有退课。我们收到了一些邮件。人们说：“潘一直在勇敢地为自己发声。她为什么不直接退课呢？”
I don't know. I sympathized. I felt like she's new here. She feels out of place. She just got singled out. She's going to tuck her head down and know she'll do it right the next time. Yeah, but I guess it's going to mean she misses her actual first class. Back in the office, Holly hears this coughing, right? She's at her cubicle. Kelly is coughing. She sounds sick. Did you notice on Holly's desk what her nameplate says?
我不知道。我挺同情她的。我觉得她刚来这里。她觉得格格不入。她刚刚被单独点名了。她会把头埋起来，心想下次她会做好的。是的，但我想这意味着她错过了她真正的第一堂课。回到办公室，霍莉听到了一阵咳嗽声，对吧？她坐在自己的工位上。凯莉在咳嗽。她听起来生病了。你注意到霍莉的桌子上她的名牌写的是什么了吗？
Yes. Hollis. And then in quotes, Holly P. Flax. I did notice that. So that's her real name. Her name is Hollis. Hollis. Kelly has a talking head where she says
看到了。霍利斯（Hollis）。然后带引号写着“霍莉·P·弗拉克斯（Holly P. Flax）”。我注意到了。所以那是她的真名。她的名字叫霍利斯。霍利斯。凯莉有一个单人访谈，她说
she's on the third day of her cleanse diet, where she's doing the lemon juice, maple syrup, and cayenne pepper and water. That's all she's allowed to have. Angela, have you ever done any of these fad diets? I haven't, but I had a roommate who did something with cayenne pepper and water, and I think it just gives you the runs, right?
她正在进行排毒饮食的第三天，她只喝柠檬汁、枫糖浆、辣椒粉和水的混合物。她只被允许喝这些。安吉拉，你从来没做过这些跟风减肥法吗？我没有，但我有个室友用过辣椒粉和水做过某种尝试，我觉得那只会让你拉肚子，对吧？
You just poop. You know, I got approached to do an ad for this diet tea that's supposed to flatten your tummy. So you drink the tea. And it flattens your tummy. How? By making you poop a lot. Well.
你就会排便。你知道的，有人找我拍一个广告，推广一种号称能让你瘦肚子的减肥茶。所以你喝这种茶。然后它就能让你的肚子变平。怎么做到的？通过让你疯狂拉肚子。好吧。
But it was like a cleansing tea. And I was like, well, first of all, I'm not going to do an ad for anything I don't believe in. So send me the tea and we'll see what happens. Did you drink the tea? I was doing Splitting Up Together at the time and I was talking to Oliver Hudson about it and he said, I'll do it with you. Let's both do the tea and see if we get flat tummies. He's so funny.
但这就像是一种排毒茶。我就想，首先，我绝不会为任何我不相信的东西拍广告。所以把茶寄给我，我们看看会发生什么。你喝了那茶吗？我当时正在拍《分道扬镳》，我跟奥利弗·哈德森聊起这事，他说：“我和你一起。我们俩都喝这茶，看看我们的肚子会不会变平。”他太搞笑了。
But I can so hear him saying that because he's just like, let's do it. He was all in. So I asked for two packages of the tea. Oliver and I started doing it. Angela. Did you poop? First of all, I gained weight. What?
但我完全能听到他说出这种话，因为他就是那种人，会说“我们干吧”。他完全投入了。所以我索要了两包茶。奥利弗和我开始喝了。安吉拉。你拉肚子了吗？首先，我体重增加。什么？
Second of all, we're just pooping and farting and just, we're trying to work and do our scenes. The crew was like, stop drinking the tea, you guys. You're like, we're farting them out. They're like, seriously, we cannot have the two leads of our show drinking this tea. Being so flatulent on set. It's ruining everything.
其次，我们一直在拉肚子和放屁，我们只是在努力工作和演戏。剧组人员说：“你们俩别喝这茶了。”你们就像是在说：“我们在排气呢。”他们说：“说真的，我们不能让剧里两个主演喝这种茶。在片场放屁放得这么厉害。这把一切都搞砸了。”
So I just, I don't know. I just don't do this stuff. Well, you know my husband, he's super healthy and he just makes really good choices about what he eats and he exercises. It's really annoying, and he just makes really good choices about what he eats, and he exercises. It's really annoying, his ability to be so consistent. My hardest struggle is consistency, you know, just like making that space for myself. And I think it's even like when you peel back the layer, it's like making that time for yourself. And it's just a hard
所以我只是，我不知道。我就是不搞这些花样。好吧，你知道我丈夫，他超级健康，他对他吃的东西总是做出很好的选择，而且他会锻炼。这真的很烦人，他对他吃的东西总是做出很好的选择，而且他会锻炼。这真的很烦人，他能做到这么有规律。我最大的挣扎就是保持规律，你知道的，就是为自己腾出那个空间。我觉得甚至就像当你剥开这一层，就像是为自己抽出那个时间。这真的是一件很难
thing to do. Yeah. Well, I think we should take a break because I need a moment to center myself before Jan comes into the office. Oh, oh yes. And there's some really good Jan stuff I want to share. All right, we'll be right back. We are back and so is Jan. Oh yeah.
做到的事。好吧，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为在珍走进办公室之前，我需要一点时间来调整一下状态。哦，哦，是的。而且有一些关于珍的非常好的内容我想分享。好的，我们马上回来。我们回来了，珍也回来了。哦，是的。
Jan enters the office and tells Ronnie to make her some copies of a document on Canary Yellow Paper. Oh yeah, she walks in like she owns the place. She also does not acknowledge that she's speaking to a person she's never met. Oh yeah, that's true. This made me wonder if Jan is entertaining Michael being in her life again so she can just use him and use the office. She's getting free copies, right?
珍走进了办公室，告诉罗妮用金丝雀黄的纸给她复印一份文件。哦，是的，她大摇大摆地走进来，就像这里是她家开的一样。而且她甚至没有承认她是在跟一个她从未见过的人说话。哦，是的，确实如此。这让我不禁怀疑，珍是不是在考虑让迈克尔重新回到她的生活中，这样她就可以利用他，利用这个办公室。她在白嫖复印件，对吧？
Yeah. Well, in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of a runner about this. She is giving Michael like a list of things she needs him to do. All her errands, go to the dry cleaner, she hands him a bag, like grocery shopping, et cetera, like Michael is her personal assistant. And then when he kind of boxed at anything, she's like, well, I thought you wanted to help. Wow.
对。好吧，在被删减的片段里，有一个关于这方面的小桥段。她给迈克尔列了一张她需要他做的事情的清单。她所有的差事，去干洗店，她递给他一个袋子，比如去杂货店买东西等等，就像迈克尔是她的私人助理一样。然后当他对任何事情面露难色时，她就会说：“嗯，我还以为你想帮忙呢。”哇。
So to me, I feel like Jan is using him. For sure. Jim has this talking head where he says, Michael led us to believe he was the father of Jan's baby by telling us he was the father of Jan's baby. Well, this talking head would have continued and they had to trim it. And Jim then holds up an email and says, but then Jan sent this email to everyone. And here's what Jan's email said.
所以对我来说，我觉得珍在利用他。肯定的。吉姆有一个单人访谈，他说迈克尔通过告诉我们他是珍孩子的父亲，让我们相信他是珍孩子的父亲。好吧，这个单人访谈本来会继续下去的，但他们不得不剪掉了一部分。然后吉姆举起一封电子邮件说：“但接着珍把这封电子邮件发给了所有人。”以下是珍的电子邮件内容：
Hi everyone. Jan here writing to share some wonderful news and to squash a rumor. First, the great news I am expecting! The beautiful baby girl inside me will be ready to meet the world this fall, just a few months before the launch of the new Serenity by Jan line. Shameless plug, I know. Don't hate me. LOL. Anyway, I also wanted to clarify that the father is not anyone that you or I have ever met. Remember, no matter how excited someone is about my baby, it does not make them the father. Best Jan.
大家好。我是珍，写信来分享一些好消息并澄清一个谣言。首先，好消息是我怀孕了！我体内的美丽小女孩将在今年秋天准备好与世界见面，就在“珍的宁静”新系列发布前几个月。毫不掩饰的软广，我懂。别恨我。哈哈。无论如何，我还想澄清的是，孩子的父亲不是你或我见过的任何人。记住，不管别人对我的孩子有多激动，这都不会让他们成为孩子的父亲。致意，珍。
P.S. hope to ship you something soon. That's amazing. Yeah. So she sent that email to everyone in the office. Well, Holly would like to know who is Jan. She says, who's that woman in Michael's office with the feet? Because Michael is rubbing Jan's feet. Oscar explains that she's Michael's ex-girlfriend. And Holly immediately decides, yes, you can give your yoga teacher my number. I want to
附言：希望很快能给你们发货（寄点东西给你们）。太惊人了。是的。所以她把这封邮件发给了办公室里的每一个人。好吧，霍莉想知道珍是谁。她说：“迈克尔办公室里那个脚放在桌上（长着脚）的女人是谁？”因为迈克尔正在给珍揉脚。奥斯卡解释说她是迈克尔的前女友。霍莉立刻做出了决定：“对，你可以把我的电话号码给你那个瑜伽教练。我想
date your hot yoga teacher. Yeah. His hot, hot yoga teacher, because he teaches hot yoga teacher my number. I want to date your hot yoga teacher. His hot hot yoga teacher because he teaches hot yoga and he's hot. I'm sure he's very bendy. Yeah. Yeah. Then Holly overhears Angela berating Kevin for being an idiot. And Holly is going to come to Kevin's defense because remember Dwight told Holly that Kevin was there as part of a special work program. Yeah, remember Dwight told Holly that Kevin was there
和你的热瑜伽教练约会。”对。她那个性感的热瑜伽教练，因为他教……把我的号码给你那个热瑜伽教练。我想和你的热瑜伽教练约会。他那个性感的热瑜伽教练，因为他教热瑜伽而且他很性感。我敢肯定他身体非常柔软。对。对。然后霍莉无意中听到安吉拉训斥凯文是个笨蛋。霍莉决定站出来为凯文辩护，因为记得德怀特曾告诉霍莉，凯文之所以在那里是因为一个特殊的工作项目。对，记得德怀特告诉霍莉凯文在那里
as part of a special work program. Yeah when Dwight was hazing her. Yeah. Oh she runs over to Angela and she's like how dare you you don't speak to him like that. And this is when everyone realizes including Kevin what Dwight told Holly. Angela is so delighted by this moment. She can't stop smiling. No, she loves that Holly has been humiliated. Poor Kevin. He's crushed. This means that Holly has not been paying attention to him because she wants to date him. No. He's realizing. Well, now Andy is going to approach Angela in the kitchen. He has made non-refundable deposits at four different wedding locations. Hot air balloons over Napa Valley,
是一个特殊工作项目的一部分。对，当时德怀特在整蛊她。对。哦，她跑向安吉拉，说道：“你怎么敢这样，你不能那样跟他说话。”这时所有人都意识到，包括凯文在内，德怀特对霍莉说了什么。安吉拉被这一刻逗乐极了。她笑得合不拢嘴。不，她很喜欢霍莉被羞辱的样子。可怜的凯文。他心碎了。这意味着霍莉根本没有注意到他，因为她想和他约会。不。他意识到了。好吧，现在安迪要在厨房里接近安吉拉了。他在四个不同的婚礼地点支付了不可退还的定金。纳帕谷的热气球、
world famous Walt Disney's Epcot Center, scuba diving wedding in the Bahamas, and the Wilkes Bar Marriott Ballroom C, to which she replies, dangerous, tacky, sharks, haunted. And no. And, oh. Just in general. And no. And, oh. Just in general. And no.
世界闻名的华特迪士尼艾克波特中心、巴哈马群岛的水肺潜水婚礼，以及威尔克斯巴里万豪酒店C宴会厅，对此她回答道：“危险、俗气、有鲨鱼、闹鬼。还有，不要。还有，哦。总体而言。还有，不要。还有，哦。总体而言。还有，不要。”
And of course, this means Angela and Dwight are going to hook up again. We had a fan question. Kayla would like to know when Dwight slaps Angela's butt, was that scripted because she thought your reaction was very genuine. You were surprised. No, that was improvised. That was Rainn Wilson. But now listen, you guys, Rainn and I were very, very good friends. And we would always do a few takes where we would try to surprise each other a little bit within the boundaries of what I knew would not make anyone uncomfortable and vice versa.
当然，这意味着安吉拉和德怀特又要搞在一起了。我们有一个粉丝提问。凯拉想知道，当德怀特拍打安吉拉的屁股时，那是剧本写好的吗，因为她觉得你的反应非常真实。你很吃惊。不，那是即兴发挥。那是雷恩·威尔逊。但听着，伙计们，雷恩和我是非常非常好的朋友。我们总是会拍几个镜头，试图在不让人感到不舒服的界限内给对方一个小惊喜，反之亦然。
Right. And so no, that was Rainn just mixing it up, and catching me off guard, which is why my reaction is so earnest. We also got mail from Alice, who would like to ask Angela in your talking head afterwards, was any of that improvised because it's one of my all-time favorites? You know what?
对。所以不，那只是雷恩在即兴发挥，把我弄了个措手不及，这就是为什么我的反应那么真诚。我们还收到了来自爱丽丝的邮件，她想问安吉拉，在你随后的单人访谈中，有任何一部分是即兴发挥的吗，因为这是我所有最喜欢的片段之一？你知道吗？
People quote this talking head to me, and it was completely scripted, and it read like this. I have a nice comforter and several cozy pillows. I usually read a chapter of a book and it's lights out by 8.30. That's how I sleep at night. Completely scripted. You go to bed at 8.30.
人们经常对我说这段单人访谈里的台词，但它完全是按剧本演的，剧本上是这样写的：“我有一条漂亮的舒适被子和几个舒适的枕头。我通常读一章书，8点30分准时熄灯。这就是我晚上的睡眠方式。”完全是按剧本演的。你8点30分就睡觉。
I know, I have lots of cats to take care of. They get up early. Well now, Jim and Pam are gonna talk via video call. You guys, old tech alert. This was a real big deal. They get up early. Well now, Jim and Pam are gonna talk via video call. You guys, old tech alert, this was a real big deal. This was an actual live iChat. Remember iChat? Yeah. Yeah.
我知道，我有好多猫要照顾。它们起得可早了。好吧，现在，吉姆和潘将通过视频通话聊天。伙计们，老科技警报。这可是一件大事。它们起得可早了。好吧，现在，吉姆和潘将通过视频通话聊天。伙计们，老科技警报，这可是一件大事。这是一个真正的实况iChat。还记得iChat吗？对。对。
This is before Zoom. This is before FaceTime. Yeah. And you know, Dwight is annoyed. Michael is so excited and picks up the computer and wants to show Pam all around. I know, which is making her a little sick. She's like, can you please put me down? I thought it was so cute.
这是在Zoom出现之前。这是在FaceTime出现之前。对。而且你知道的，德怀特很恼火。迈克尔超级兴奋，拿起电脑想带潘到处看看。我知道，这让她有点恶心。她说：“你能把我放下吗？”我觉得这太可爱了。
Guys, this happened in real time. We had some questions from Alice R. and Brianna P. How'd you shoot the video chat scenes? Well, it was live. They built a little set over on the warehouse set to look like my dorm room at Pratt. And I sat there and we did this live. It was really cute.
伙计们，这是实时发生的。我们收到了来自爱丽丝·R和布里安娜·P的一些问题。你们是怎么拍摄视频聊天场景的？嗯，那是实况。他们在仓库布景旁边搭建了一个小布景，看起来就像我在普拉特的宿舍。我坐在那里，我们进行了实时拍摄。真的很可爱。
Yeah. And I have to say, I was really excited because during most of this episode, I was not on our set. I was really filming on location to film Pam's art school. And so for this day, I just remember how excited I was. Even though I was all the way on the warehouse set, I was able to come over for hot snack.
对。而且我必须说，我真的很兴奋，因为在这集的绝大部分时间里，我都不在我们的片场。我实际上是在外景地拍摄潘的艺术学校。所以对于这一天，我只记得我是多么兴奋。尽管我远在仓库片场，我还是能过来吃个热乎的点心。
I stayed for lunch. Yes, this was one of the hardest things for us as BFFs is when you were at the Pratt School of Art, you were not on our set, you were on location. So I was so excited you were there. And one thing I wanna share about this that Randy talked about in the DVD commentary is that this live iChat Jenna
我留下来吃午饭了。是的，作为闺蜜，对我们来说最难的事情之一就是当你去普拉特艺术学院时，你不在我们的片场，你在外景地。所以我超级高兴你在那儿。关于这一点，我想分享的一件事是兰迪在DVD评论中谈到的，那就是这个实况iChat，詹娜，
caused all kinds of technical problems. I remember. Yeah, I remember, because we had to start and stop. Here's what happened. The wireless microwave system on the side of the cameras would get triggered whenever Steve picked up the laptop and walked around with you. It would shut the cameras off, which meant we got to hang out a little bit because they had to sort that out.
引发了各种技术问题。我记得。是的，我记得，因为我们不得不停停拍拍。事情是这样的：每当迈克尔拿起笔记本电脑带着你到处走时，摄像机侧面的无线微波系统就会被触发。它会关闭摄像机，这意味着我们得以一起闲逛一会儿，因为他们必须解决这个问题。
I just remember shooting the talking head and I thought it was so cute the way they put the computer on the chair. I did too. Well now the gang is going to weigh in again. And guess what? They've gained five pounds and then Kelly passes out. And we go to commercial. We come back with some real Phyllis sass.
我只记得拍摄那个单人访谈时，我觉得他们把电脑放在椅子上的方式太可爱了。我也觉得。好吧，现在大家要再次称量体重了。你猜怎么着？他们胖了五磅，然后凯莉晕倒了。然后我们进入广告时间。我们带着菲尔·萨斯的满满讽刺回归了。
Phyllis is super smug with Angela and she's planning Stanley's birthday party and she's just giving Angela marching orders. She is. She would like to get some cake. And anytime Angela seems like she might disagree, Phyllis just kind of gives a little look like we will be doing it this way and here's why. Yeah and there was more Phyllis sass in the deleted scenes. She was giving Angela grief this whole episode. Well we talked about this at the end of Goodbye Toby. Phyllis catches Dwight and Angela getting it on in the office and we wondered, what does this mean? Well, it has gone to Phyllis's head. She has power. Holly suggests that they do fruit instead of cake. Michael comes in, he's gonna weigh in, he suddenly has a goatee, no explanation.
菲尔对安吉拉极其自鸣得意，她在筹办斯坦利的生日派对，她简直是在对安吉拉下达命令。确实如此。她想弄点蛋糕。每当安吉拉看起来好像要反对时，菲尔就会抛出一个眼神，仿佛在说“我们就要这么办，原因如下”。是的，在被删减的片段里还有更多菲尔的讽刺。她整集都在给安吉拉找麻烦。好吧，我们在《告别托比》的结尾讨论过这个。菲尔撞见德怀特和安吉拉在办公室里亲热，我们当时想，这意味着什么？好吧，这冲昏了菲尔的头脑。她有权力了。霍莉建议他们用水果代替蛋糕。迈克尔进来了，他要称体重，他突然留了一撮山羊胡，没有任何解释。
Yeah. But he has a goatee. Kelly Cantley said that goatee took an hour to put on, so they had to factor that into the day. He didn't just grow a goatee? No, none of their goatees were real. No. That's what she said.
是的。但他留了山羊胡。凯莉·坎特利说，那撮山羊胡花了一个小时才贴上，所以他们必须把这个时间计入当天的日程中。他不是自己长出来的一撮山羊胡？不，他们的山羊胡都不是真的。不。她是这么说的。
No, none of them? They were all put on, and then they had to keep track that they were the right shape and size goatee throughout the episode for continuity. And Kelly said at the time this aired, they got some mail that a few of the goatees were off. Oh my gosh. Well, Michael is gonna take his goatee into the conference room and he's going
不，都不是？它们都是贴上去的，然后他们必须确保在整集节目中，山羊胡的形状和大小都保持一致，以便连戏。凯莉说，在这一集播出时，他们收到了一些邮件，说有几处山羊胡贴歪了。天哪。好吧，迈克尔要把他的山羊胡带进会议室，他要
to call a meeting because he wants everyone to know what is the leading cause of death. It is obesity caused illness. He wants everyone to take this more seriously so they don't die of obesity. Jim pledges to lose 65 pounds. He's being sarcastic. Michael doesn't get it. He's thrilled. He says, if everybody loses five pounds, that in addition to Jim's 65, we're going to win this thing. Well, Angela has presented Andy with her list of criteria for her wedding. It's pretty challenging. Here are the things she has to have in order to marry Andy.
开个会，因为他想让每个人都知道导致死亡的主要原因是什么。那就是肥胖引起的疾病。他希望每个人都对此更加重视，这样就不会死于肥胖。吉姆发誓要减掉65磅。他在讽刺。迈克尔没听出来。他兴奋极了。他说，如果每个人都减掉5磅，再加上吉姆的65磅，我们就能赢了。好吧，安吉拉向安迪提出了她对婚礼的标准清单。这相当具有挑战性。以下是她为了嫁给安迪必须满足的条件。
Okay. A thousand-year-old church in the continental United States. There has to be a rainbow. 24-hour veterinarian on call. And then she pages Dwight to meet her downstairs because she just can't really stand being around Andy. But Andy tells Angela, you know what? I don't care where we get married because all I care about is spending the rest of my life with you. This melts Angela's cold, cold heart. It does.
好的。美国本土一座有一千年历史的教堂。必须有彩虹。24小时待命的兽医。然后她用寻呼机叫德怀特下楼见她，因为她实在有点无法忍受和安迪待在一起。但安迪对安吉拉说，你知道吗？我不在乎我们在哪里结婚，因为我唯一在乎的就是和你度过余生。这融化了安吉拉冰冷冰冷的心。确实如此。
And she does not show up for her rendezvous with Dwight in the warehouse. She gives Andy a little kiss. And of course he has to make a noise. He makes like a boo. Well there's a very sweet deleted scene that shows Angela trying to bond with Andy over the wedding. It's in the break room and I titled it, Overly Animated Angela? We could get a cake shaped like your cat. They can do that? Yeah. Yeah. For you, my love, I will find the finest cake-smith in all the land.
她没有去仓库赴与德怀特的约会。她给了安迪一个吻。当然，他免不了要发出声音。他发出了像“boo”一样的声音。有一个非常甜蜜的被删减片段，展示了安吉拉试图通过婚礼与安迪建立感情。它在休息室里，我给它起名叫：过度生动的安吉拉？我们可以定制一个做成你猫形状的蛋糕。他们能做到这点？对。对。为了你，我的爱人，我将走遍全大陆寻找最优秀的蛋糕大师。
Bring me some baked salats of frosting ham forest. What about one shaped like, I don't know, a litter box? Hey-o! Right? I mean is it gross or wonderful? Ah! I don't know! I'll be at my desk. Page me if you need me. Who are you? I know! Ah! I don't know! I'll be at my desk. Page me if you need me. Who are you? I know! Ah! I don't know! Who is this person?
给我带点毛草地霜饰的烘焙沙拉火腿来。那做一个形状像，我不知道，猫砂盆的蛋糕怎么样？嘿哦！对吧？我的意思是，这到底是恶心还是绝妙？啊！我不知道！我会在我的桌子旁。如果有需要就用寻呼机找我。你是谁？我知道！啊！我不知道！我会在我的桌子旁。如果有需要就用寻呼机找我。你是谁？我知道！啊！我不知道！这个人是谁？
I don't know! Oh, overly animated Angela. She was trying. Maybe he should just do some Mad Libs. You love those. I love Mad Libs and keep suggesting cakes that look like cats or cat accessories. It's the way to your heart. Well Jim has arrived at Pam's dorm room.
我不知道！哦，过度生动的安吉拉。她真的很努力。也许他应该玩一些疯狂填词（Mad Libs）。你最喜欢那些了。我喜欢疯狂填词，并且一直建议做成猫或猫奴配件形状的蛋糕。这是通往你心的捷径。好吧，吉姆已经到达了潘的宿舍。
Did you notice that Pam is the resident advisor? I did. She's the RA. It's so perfect. It's perfect, but it's also like Pam. Take on a job. Come on. Well Jim tells the documentary crew, you know what, why don't you go check out Pam's art
你注意到潘是宿舍管理员（RA）了吗？我注意到了。她是RA。这太完美了。这很完美，但也挺像潘的风格。承担起一份工作。拜托。好吧，吉姆对纪录片摄制组说，你知道吗，你们为什么不去看看潘的艺术作品
over there? And when they turn to look for it, he quickly shuts the door, right? And at 18 minutes 31 seconds, you hear the cameraman's sigh. You hear Randall Einhorn sigh. Yes, that's Randall. And that was improvised. He just did that and they loved it and they kept it in. Oh yeah, So fun.
那边呢？当他们转身去找时，他迅速关上了门，对吧？在18分31秒时，你能听到摄影师的叹气声。你能听到兰德尔·艾恩霍恩叹气。是的，那是兰德尔。那是即兴发挥。他只是叹了口气，他们觉得很棒就保留下来了。哦，是的，太有趣了。
I would like to say, Pam, thank you for finally wearing a hoodie or any kind of casual clothing here at art school. I feel like she just has been overdressed since she got there. We are on two different pages on this. I think that Pam has looked amazing for art school. I love her ponytail. I just think, and this was a choice, that I should say that this has all been a choice.
我想说，潘，谢谢你终于在艺术学校穿了一件连帽衫或任何类型的休闲服装。我觉得自从她到了那里之后，她就一直穿着过度。在这个问题上我们俩看法完全不同。我认为潘在艺术学校里的穿着看起来惊艳极了。我喜欢她的马尾辫。我只是觉得，这是一个选择，我应该说这一切都是一个选择。
It's on purpose. It's all to make her stand out a little bit, to be like she isn't dressing the way the young people dress today. Right. Okay, so like I'm giving her grief about it, but you guys, we planned this. Right, and also her affected speech,
这是故意的。这一切都是为了让她稍微显眼一点，就像她没有穿今天年轻人那样的衣服一样。对。好吧，所以我虽然在为此挑她的刺，但伙计们，这是我们策划好的。对，还有她那做作的谈吐，
how she's like, top of the morning to ya. Shall we walk over here? Perhaps we'll sit here. Let me cross my legs in my stockings. What are you talking about? That's how she talks. No, she does not. What are you doing? I'm just messing with you. I really got worried. I was like, what? I am messing with you. I don't know how long Jim and Pam got to hang out and smooch, but Pam got a knock on her door. There was some girl mad at another girl because someone took someone's soy milk. And now Jim is in like the dorm room common area at 18 minutes, 55 seconds. Yeah, he's watching a baseball game.
她说话的语气就像是“早安啊。我们要不要走到这边来？也许我们会坐在这里。让我把穿着丝袜的双腿交叠起来。”你在说什么？她就是那样说话的。不，她才不那样。你在干什么？我只是在逗你玩。我刚才真的担心坏了。我想：什么？我是在逗你玩。我不知道吉姆和潘聚在一起卿卿我我了多久，但潘的宿舍门被敲响了。有个女孩生另一个女孩的气，因为有人拿了某个人的豆奶。现在吉姆在宿舍的公共区域，时间是18分55秒。对，他在看棒球比赛。
Yes. And Jenna, you can very faintly hear some sort of baseball commentators like announcers, sports announcers. Yeah. Those were played by our very own producer, James O'Carrie and Eric Colgin. All right, see, I wondered, is that a real baseball game? So it's obviously real baseball footage,
是的。而且詹娜，你能非常微弱地听到某种棒球评论员的声音，比如播音员、体育播音员。是的。那是我们的制片人詹姆斯·奥凯里（James O'Carrie）和埃里克·科尔金（Eric Colgin）配音的。好吧，你看，我当时想，那真的是一场棒球比赛吗？所以这显然是真正的棒球比赛画面，
but then we put our own commentators on it. That's right. So Jenna and I have been in touch with James. He is fantastic. He was that guy that could like get you anything on set. If you needed it, James got it. And we had lots of questions for him and he answered them for this episode. He even had the shooting draft.
但随后我们在上面加入了我们自己的解说员声音。没错。所以詹娜和我一直与詹姆斯保持着联系。他太棒了。他就是那种能在片场为你搞定任何事情的人。如果你需要什么，詹姆斯就能弄到。我们向他提出了很多问题，他为这一集一一作答了。他甚至还保留着拍摄剧本。
James, thank you so much. I feel like we might have a James-opedia. Yeah, it couldn't come at a better time. Yeah. You know, because we don't have Kent-opedia anymore, James. James Carey, will you, will you be our James-opedia? Should we talk about Stanley's birthday? I mean, it looks a little sad. Everyone's standing around eating fruit.
詹姆斯，非常感谢你。我觉得我们可能要有一个“詹姆斯百科”了。是的，这来得正是时候。是的。你知道的，因为我们不再有“肯特百科”了，詹姆斯。詹姆斯·凯里，你愿意，你愿意成为我们的“詹姆斯百科”吗？我们该聊聊斯坦利的生日了吗？我的意思是，这看起来有点悲伤。大家围站在一起吃水果。
Ronnie wants to know if anyone wants to dance. By the way, my Dolly Parton fans, did you catch the song playing? Oh yeah. Here you come again. I love that song. I love that song too. I went and listened to it after I watched the episode.
罗妮想知道是否有人想跳舞。顺便说一句，我的多莉·帕顿粉丝们，你们捕捉到播放的歌了吗？哦，是的。你又来了（Here You Come Again）。我喜欢那首歌。我也很喜欢那首歌。看完这集后我还特意去听了。
It's not the song I would play at a birthday party. No, no, probably not. But I love that song. People are going to sneak off from this party and they're going to have some cake in the warehouse. The warehouse is the sneak site, clearly. Clearly, and I mean, isn't Angela uncomfortable being in that room with all those other people,
这不是我想在生日派对上播放的歌。不，不，可能不会。但我真的很喜欢那首歌。人们要从这个派对上溜走，他们要到仓库里吃点蛋糕。仓库显然是偷吃圣地。显然，我的意思是，安吉拉和所有其他人一起待在那个房间里难道不觉得尴尬吗，
including her fiance? She doesn't have any guilt about it. I guess not. She has no problem sleeping at night. We've established that. That's true. Stanley is in the room with the cake, but he's any guilt about it. I guess not. She has no problem sleeping at night. We've established that. That's true. Stanley is in the room with the cake,
包括她的未婚夫在内？她对此没有任何负罪感。我想没有吧。她晚上睡觉很踏实。我们已经确认过了。确实如此。斯坦利在有蛋糕的房间里，但他甚至
but he's not even eating it. He said his tastes have changed. Now all he likes is baklava, which I thought was a really interesting thing to say, because baklava is very, very, very sweet. Like if you've lost your sweet tooth. I mean, it's nutty. I love a baklava.
都没有吃。他说他的口味变了。现在他只喜欢果仁蜜饼（baklava），我觉得这是一个非常有趣的点，因为果仁蜜饼非常非常非常甜。就像如果你失去了对甜食的喜爱。我的意思是，它是坚果味的。我很喜欢果仁蜜饼。
I do too. It's dense, though. It's a dense, sugary treat. I know. And I often eat too's nutty. I love a baklava. I do too. It's dense though. It's a dense sugary treat. I know. And I often eat too much of it and I get a stomachache because, you know, they give you a tiny piece and I'll eat like five of them because they're just so good. Well, that's what happens with you. You're always like, Ang, look how cute. It's so tiny. I know. And then you're like, Ang, I have a stomachache.
我也是。不过它很扎实。这是一种扎实的含糖甜点。我知道。而且我经常吃得太多，然后胃痛，因为，你知道的，他们给你一小块，我会吃上五块，因为它们太好吃了。好吧，你就是这样。你总是说：“安，看多可爱。它太小了。”我知道。然后你就会说：“安，我胃痛。”
I know. Dwight, Holly, Michael and Ronnie spy on the group. Dwight's like, they should not be in there. You know why he's saying that. And Michael says, we should have our own party. Let's all go play mini golf. Ronnie and Michael and Dwight and Holly, that foursome. Oh, I wish that happened. Me too.
我知道。德怀特、霍莉、迈克尔和罗妮在暗中监视这群人。德怀特说：“他们不应该在里面。”你知道他为什么这么说。迈克尔说：“我们应该办我们自己的派对。我们去打迷你高尔夫吧。”罗妮、迈克尔、德怀特和霍莉，这四人组。哦，我真希望这一幕发生过。我也是。
Well, Holly can't go because she has a date tonight. Hmm. And then Michael has the sweetest talking head. He's like, Holly doesn't need any luck. Everyone who meets her instantly loves her. Yeah. So cute. I want these two kids to get together. Angela, I have a question for you about the next scene,
好吧，霍莉不能去，因为她今晚有约会。嗯。然后迈克尔有了一段最甜美的单人访谈。他说：“霍莉不需要什么好运。每个遇到她的人都会立刻爱上她。”是的，太可爱了。我希望这两个小家伙能在一起。安吉拉，关于下一个场景，我有一个问题想问你，
which is when Dwight busts in and he kicks over the cake. Yeah. I wasn't there. I'm at art school. What was it like to shoot that scene? Here's the thing. That room was like, I mean, Jenna, it was like six feet by six feet. It is really small and we were all in there.
也就是德怀特闯进来把蛋糕踢翻的那场戏。对。我当时不在。我在艺术学校。拍那场戏是什么感觉？情况是这样的。那个房间就像是，我的意思是，詹娜，它大约只有六英尺乘六英尺。它真的很小，我们所有人都挤在里面。
They tried to put chairs in so that we could sit, but not everyone could sit, obviously. We were pretty crammed in. I remember I couldn't look at Phyllis or I would laugh. Whenever she had her exchange with Michael, she would kind of start to break a little. And then Rain kicked over that cake with such like force. It went flying. We all got cake on us. And then they would have to clean it up. We couldn't do it very many times because we were like, Rain, do you have to kick it that hard? So pretty much I just remember being crammed in and trying not to laugh. Well I thought that scene looked like it was a lot of fun to shoot and I know don't ask Rainn Wilson to kick something unless you really want it kicked. Yeah unless you want it to go flying. Yeah. I don't think they anticipated that that much cake
他们试图放几把椅子进去好让我们坐下，但显然不是所有人都能坐。我们挤得满满当当的。我记得我不能看菲尔，否则我会笑出来。每当她和迈克尔有对手戏时，她总是有点快要笑场了。然后雷恩带着巨大的力量把那个蛋糕踢飞了。蛋糕满天飞。我们身上都沾了蛋糕。然后他们不得不清理干净。我们没法拍太多次，因为我们在想：“雷恩，你非得踢得那么狠吗？”所以基本上我只记得当时挤得要命，还要努力憋笑。好吧，我觉得那场戏看起来拍得非常开心，而且我知道，千万别让雷恩·威尔逊踢什么东西，除非你是真心想把它踢飞。对，除非你想让它飞起来。对。我想他们没有预料到会有那么多蛋糕
would travel, because it was quite a cleanup. Well, now it is week five of the weight loss competition. The Scranton branch is not doing very well. Holly tells us that corporate has now upped the prize to five vacation days, but things are breaking down between people. I mean, Kevin's in the kitchen. He's making himself a peanut butter bagel.
到处飞，因为善后工作可真不轻松。好吧，现在是减肥比赛的第五周。斯克兰顿分公司表现得不是很好。霍莉告诉我们，总公司现在将奖品提高到了五天带薪休假，但人们之间的关系正在崩溃。我的意思是，凯文在厨房里。他正在给自己做一个花生酱贝果。
Creed and Kelly are glaring at him. Oh, there's a deleted scene where Meredith and Kelly and Holly are working on the dry erase board. Yeah. And Kelly goes, I'm doing a blood type diet. And Meredith goes, who gives a fuck? And Kelly goes, what'd you say, whore? And Holly goes, I got it, okay, hey, hey, hey.
克里德和凯莉怒视着他。哦，有一个被删减的片段，梅雷迪思、凯莉和霍莉在干擦白板前工作。对。然后凯莉说：“我在进行血型饮食法。”梅雷迪思说：“谁他妈在乎啊？”凯莉说：“你刚说什么，婊子？”霍莉说：“我懂了，好吧，嘿，嘿，嘿。”
Oh my gosh. I mean, things are getting really intense. They're so intense that Kelly says in a talking head that she swallowed a tapeworm last night that Creed gave her from Mexico. Kelly, why would you swallow a worm Creed gave you? I know, Creed says it wasn't a tapeworm. Angela, I'll have you know, I looked it up.
我的天呐。我的意思是，情况变得非常激烈。激烈到凯莉在单人访谈中说，她昨晚吞下了一条克里德从墨西哥给她的绦虫。凯莉，你为什么要吞下克里德给你的虫子？我知道，克里德说那不是绦虫。安吉拉，实话告诉你，我查过资料。
Yeah. The tapeworm diet is a real thing. Oh, God, really? Well, it's obviously illegal in the United States, and it's totally dangerous. Where are they doing it? I don't know, but I guess you can buy pills that have a tapeworm egg inside of it. Don't do this. No, I read on Healthline that it doesn't even work because yes, it feeds off your body's nutrients,
对。绦虫减肥法是真实存在的。哦，天哪，真的吗？好吧，这在美国显然是违法的，而且绝对是危险的。他们在哪里做这事？我不知道，但我猜你能买到里面有绦虫卵的药丸。千万别这么做。不，我在Healthline上看到过，这根本不管用，因为没错，它会吸取你身体的营养，
but it feeds off the good stuff too, right? It doesn't just eat your fat, everybody. It eats everything and you get really sick. You can get diarrhea, abdominal pain, nausea, fever, weakness. You can also get bacterial infections. You can get neurological issues. Most of these pills are a scam.
但它连好东西也一起吸取，对吧？各位，它不仅仅吃你的脂肪。它什么都吃，然后你会变得病得很重。你会腹泻、腹痛、恶心、发烧、虚弱。你还会感染细菌。你会出现神经系统问题。这些药丸大多是个骗局。
Okay, they do not really have a tapeworm, but a woman in Iowa swallowed a real one and she got super sick and she had to confess to her doctor what she did. He had to report it to the State Department. It was a whole crazy thing. He didn't even know how to kill it. It was a whole thing.
好吧，它们实际上并没有绦虫，但爱荷华州有一个女人吞了一条真的绦虫，她病得非常重，不得不向医生坦白她做了什么。他不得不将其上报给州卫生部门。整个过程疯狂极了。他甚至不知道该怎么杀死它。这真是一团糟。
Guys, do not swallow a tapeworm on purpose. Our words I'm saying just in case anyone out there thought they should. You know, Jenna, I have a tapeworm story. But you know I'm going gonna save it for the finale. When we are done with the whole run of the office, you will remember. I don't wanna spoil it.
伙计们，千万不要故意吞绦虫。我特此声明，以防有人觉得他们应该这么做。你知道的，詹娜，我有一个关于绦虫的故事。但你知道我会把它留到大结局再讲。等我们把《办公室》整部剧都播完时，你会记起来的。我不想剧透。
There is a scene in the finale. I don't wanna spoil it. You'll remember, Jenna. Rain and I traded tapeworm stories. I'm saving it for the finale. Guys, if you've ever had a reason... To tune in... To at least our finale episode of Office Ladies, you have it now.
大结局里有一场戏。我不想剧透。你会记起来的，詹娜。雷恩和我交换过绦虫的故事。我把它留到大结局。伙计们，如果你曾经有过任何理由……来收看……至少是我们《办公室女士》的最后一集节目，那么你现在有了。
There is a real life Angela Reign moment that happens behind the scenes of the finale. It involves a tapeworm. We'll get to it. Well, guys, that's weight loss part one. We will be back next week with weight loss part two when Jim has a big surprise for Pam. We're gonna tell you all about it. Aww, Jam fans, you don't want to miss it. See you then. See ya.
大结局的幕后发生了一个现实生活中的安吉拉和雷恩的时刻。它跟绦虫有关。我们到时候会讲到。好吧，伙计们，这就是《减肥》上集。我们下周将带着《减肥》下集回归，届时吉姆为潘准备了一个巨大的惊喜。我们会把一切都告诉你们。噢，詹姆（Jam）粉丝们，你们绝对不想错过。到时候见。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特森的《橡胶树》。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。